MORNING WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND GET STARTED WITH TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO RETURN DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
INSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY. WHILE ALLOWING FOR
FULL PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. TO THEIR ROOM FOR
THIRTY SEVEN WE ARE HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANT AND PERSON
HEARING. WE CAN ONLY WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS
A MINIMAL CONTENT IN THE STAFF
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO YOU CAN
KEEP SIX FEET OF SPACE. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL THE SYSTEM
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE DOESN'T PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND THE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK. THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I WILL ASK THEM TO
PUT THE MICROPHONE. WE'LL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER WE'VE
HEARD ALL THE ITEMS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC RESPECT THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND I TOOK THE
MICROPHONE. WE WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HAREM WANTED- YOUR
PUBLIC COMMUNIST ON A RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT THE PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. THE PANELS
FOR TODAY'S HEARING ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY TODAY I ASK
THAT EVERYONE SILENCE
ELECTRONIC DEVICES AND PEACE
MEET YOURSELF WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING. THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THAT
THERE WILL BE NO VOTE IN THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. TODAY SEVERAL
FOCUS ON TWO ITEMS THE FIRST
ITEM FOR DISCUSSION AT THE
RECENT AUDIT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
THE PHARMACY OF FUNDING MANDATE
A FOREIGN BUYER MENTAL TRAINING
AND ENFORCEMENT. AS WELL AS THE
AS PROSECUTION OF WORKPLACE
SAFETY ISSUES. CDA WAS INVITED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
TO PROVIDE US WITH THEIR
RESPONSE TO THE AUDIT. AS LAWS
THAT THEY'VE TAKEN A PLAN TO
TAKE TO ADDRESS THE AUDIT
FINDINGS CDA HAS DECLINED TO
PARTICIPATE. IN TODAY'S HEARING
DUE TO THE OPEN INVESTIGATION
OF THE AUDIT BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. NEVERTHELESS THE
INFORMATION THAT WE RECEIVED
TODAY WILL BE CRITICAL TO
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACT THE
MISUSE OF STATE FUNDING. HOW WE
HOLD THOSE RESPONSIBLE
ACCOUNTABLE AND WHAT MEASURES
WOULD HELP TO PREVENT THIS FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN. THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IS A RECIPIENT OF
A LETTER FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GROUP. CRIMINAL JUSTICE
GROUPS AND MOST RECENTLY LABOR
ALL EXPRESSING GREAT CONCERN AT
THE AUDIT FINDINGS AND CALLING
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY. AND FOR ALL
MISUSED MUST BE PAID BACK
IMMEDIATELY. FOR A SECOND PANEL
WE WILL. BE PROVIDED AND ALL
REVIEW EVERYTHING PUBLIC SAFETY
INVESTMENT IN POLICY CHANGES
MADE BY THE LEGISLATURE. WE
WILL ALSO HEAR FROM A DIVERSE
GROUP OF PANELISTS TO GET AN
UPDATE ON THEIR PURCHASE TO
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION STRATEGIES
THAT OVERLAP WITH THESE POLICY
CHANGES AND INVESTMENTS. THANK
YOU TO ALL THE PANELISTS FOR
JOINING OUR HEARING NOW LOOK
FORWARD TO TODAY'S DISCUSSION
AFTER EACH PANEL. I WILL OPEN
IT UP TO THE SUB COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE QUESTIONS I WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER BOTH
PANELS THAT'S INCLUDED. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I LIVE IN A
REALLY IMPACTED ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITY- AND SO IT IS
TROUBLING TO SEE THAT AN
AGENCY. AND ORGANIZATIONS THAT
IS AIMED AT HELPING TO PROTECT
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND MY
CONSTITUENTS. IS
MISAPPROPRIATING THE FUNDS
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO GO AFTER
POLLUTERS. THAT ARE MAKING A
SICK ON A REGULAR ASIS AND SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS HEARING.
DO ANY OF OUR- MY COLLEAGUES
WANT TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS
BEFORE WE START. OKAY WELL THEN
WITH THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED WITH. OUR FIRST
PANEL WHICH IS THE ORIENT A
REVIEW OFTHE STATE FUNDING. TO
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION A NOT A
FINDING. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE-
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE'RE GONNA HAVE. K. R.
THE SENIOR ODD NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL ALL PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PANEL. I NEED TO LEAVE AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE HAVING US TODAY- WE
WERE ASKED BY STAFF TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF STATE FUNDING
SOURCES TO CDA AS WELL AS AN
OVERVIEW OF THE ADDICTS. I WILL
BE SHARING MY SCREEN AND USING
THE CANNOT THAT WE'VE BEEN
WE'VE PREPARED AS A GUIDE FOR
COMMENTS TODAY. SO YOU CAN SEE
THE HANNIBAL FOR YOU- IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE ONE OF THE HAND
OUT- IF YOU'VE GOT IT BEFORE
YOU WILL JUST. PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT OF A HIGHLIGHT RELATED TO
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE OR CA. IT IS
A NOT FOR PROFIT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION THAT CONSIST OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK IN THE
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION FEELS. THE
ORGANIZATION ENGAGES IN VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES RANGING FROM
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY TO STATE
MY TRAINING. AND RECEIVES FUNDS
FROM VARIOUS SOURCES INCLUDING
MEMBERSHIP DUES- STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FINES AND
LITGATION PROCEEDS FROM STATE
AND LOCAL CASES. SOME OF THE
MONIES THAT ARE RECEIVED ARE
RESTRICTED OR REQUIRED FOR USED
FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSES. MOVING
TO THE NEXT PAGE OF OUR HAND
OUT WE'RE GONNA FIRST PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF STATE FUNDING
PROVIDED TO CDA AND RECENT
YEARS. FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIS
HAND OUT WE THINK OF STATE
FUNDING AS ANY MONIES THAT HAVE
AUTHORIZATION UNDER STATE LAW
AND THIS WILL INCLUDE ANY
FEDERAL FUNDS WHICH OTHERWISE
WOULD NOT HAVE. BEEN AVAILABLE
ON WITHOUT THE STATE'S PRESENCE
AND IT ALSO INCLUDES LITIGATION
FINES FROM CASES PURSUED BY THE
STATE. SO LOOKING AT THIS THE
FUNDING REALLY FALLS WITHIN
SEVEN CATEGORIES- THE FIRST TWO
CATEGORIES RELATES TO
ENVIRONMENTS THE ENVIRONMENTS.
THE FIRST CATEGORY IS THAT CDA
RECEIVES FUNDING TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE TRAINING ON THE
ENFORCEMENT OF STATE AND LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS INCLUDING
TEACHING PROSECUTION AND
INVESTIGATION TECHNIQUES. THE
FUNDING IS COMING FROM A STATE
ACCOUNT CALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT AND TRAINING
ACCOUNT OR ETA. AND AT LEAST
20% 25% OF THE FUNDS SUBJECT
AVAILABILITY ARE USED FOR THIS
PURPOSE. AND SO CA LAST
RECEIVED AROUND FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FROM ETA FOR THE
ACTIVITIES IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IN PRIOR
YEARS THE AMOUNT WAS HIGHER SO
THEY COULD BE FOR EXAMPLE IN
LOVE COUPLE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. THE
SECOND CATEGORY FUNDING IS FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CIRCUIT
PROSECUTOR PROJECT WHICH IS A
JOINT PROJECT BETWEEN THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY AND CDA. AND
THE PURPOSE OF THE PROJECT WAS
FOR EFFECTIVE ANDUNIFORM
ENFORCEMENT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS INCLUDING
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS UPON THEIR
REQUEST IN PROSECUTING THESE
TYPES OF CASES- SIMILAR TO THE
FIRST CATEGORY SUBJECT TO
AVAILABILITY. AT LEAST 25% OF
THE ETA MONIES ARE TO SUPPORT
CTAS COSTS FOR THIS PROJECT AND
CDA LAST RECEIVED AROUND. SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND FOR THE PROJECT
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. THE THIRD CATEGORY OF
FUNDING RELATES TO ASSET
FORFEITURE I'M STATE LAW
REQUIRES THAT STATE AND LOCAL
DRUG RELATED ASSET FORFEITURES
BE DISTRIBUTED IN A PARTICULAR
WAY AND THIS INCLUDES AN
ALLOCATION OF 1% OF PROCEEDS GO
TO A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION COMPOSED OF LOCAL
PROSECUTORS. FOR STATE MY
TRAINING IN THIS AREA AND THIS
IS TRADITIONALLY BEEN CDA SOME
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN C. A.
RECEIVED AROUND THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FROM ASSET FORFEITURE
CASES. NOT TURNING TO PAGE
THREE OF YOUR HAND OUT IF
YOU'VE GOT A BEFORE YOU THE
FOURTH CATEGORY OF FUNDING
RELATES TO THE HIGH TECHNOLOGY
THEFT APPREHENSION AND
PROSECUTION PROGRAM. WHICH WAS
CREATED BY STATE LAW TO IMPROVE
THE INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION OF THESE TYPES OF
CASES. THE FUNDS SOURCE FOR
THIS IS FROM TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT FUNDS THAT
GO TO MARIN COUNTY WHICH IS NOT
AVAILABLE FOR USE BY CDA FOR-
STATE MY TRAINING AND RESEARCH
IN THIS AREA AND WE ESTIMATE
THAT CDA RECEIVES AROUND A
HUNDRED AND. NINETY TWO
THOUSAND ANNUALLY. FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES. WHAT CATEGORY OF
FUNDING IS- STATE GRANT
PROGRAMS TO CDA HAS RECEIVED
GRANT FUNDING FROM VARIOUS
AGENCIES OVERSIGHT. AND THE
FUNDING CAN FLUCTUATE FROM YEAR
TO YEAR DEPENDING ON WHETHER OR
NOT CD EIGHT SIX THE FUNDING
AND WHETHER IT THERE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED THE GRANT AWARD. FROM
THE EXAMPLES ON THIS PAGE WILL
ALSO SEE THAT THE TIME PERIOD
COVERED BY THE GRANT. ALSO MAY
DIFFER AND TO KEEP THE APPLES
ARE RECENT GRANTS INCLUDE- ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS AND
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR- ABUSE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT MEDICAL
EVIDENTIARY EXAMINATIONS
TRAININGS. ONE POINT TWO
MILLION IN FEDERAL AND STATE
FUNDS FOR THE STATE MY TRAINING
ON. THE INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND ABUSE CASES. SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND FEDERAL FUNDS WERE
SPECIALIZED TRAINING- RELATED
TO PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL CHILD
ABUSE CASES. AND THEN FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR
SPECIALIZED- VICTIM SERVICES
TRAINING IN TERMS OF HOW. TO
DEAL WITH CERTAIN- BECOME
POPULATIONS. TURNING PAGE. OF
YOUR HAND OUT THE SIX CATEGORY
A FUNDING. IS RELATED TO MONIES
RECEIVED FROM SETTLEMENTS AND
JUDGMENTS IN CASES THAT WERE
FILED AND RESOLVED BY THE
STATE'S OF FOR EXAMPLE CDA
RECEIVED AROUND A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. RELATED
TO CONSUMER PROTECTION CASES
THAT WERE RESOLVED BY DOJ THE
AMOUNT CAN FLUCTUATE FROM YEAR
TO YEAR. THE SEVENTH AND FINAL
CATEGORY OF FUNDING IS- FROM A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES AND FROM VARIOUS
FUNDING SOURCES IT COVERS A
VARIETY OF PURPOSES RANGING
FROM ATTORNEY MEMBERSHIP DUES
TO TRAINING FEES. TO
PUBLICATIONS- CITY GIVEN CDA
NEARLY FORTY TWO THOUSAND AND
SUCH PAYMENTS FROM DOJ IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY. TURN
TO PAGE FIVE OF YOUR HAND OUT
WE ARE GOING TO SHIFT OUR
ATTENTION TO THE AUDIT- AND WE
WILL BE PROVIDING A SUMMARY OF
THE EXTERNAL AUDITS. OF CDA
THAT WAS COMPLETED IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THIS AUDIT
WAS INITIATED BY CD EIGHT IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY- THE
FOCUS WAS A SPECIFIC LINE ITEM
AUDIT OF SETTLEMENTS JUDGMENTS
AND GRANT MONIES. FOR A SUBSET
OF THEIR FUNDING- SPECIFICALLY
ROUGHLY SIX ENVIRONMENTAL AND
WORKER SAFETY RELATED C. A.
PROGRAMS GOING BACK THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO. IN TERMS OF
THE AUDITS- THE AUDITOR FOUND A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FINDINGS WE
GENERALLY FOUND THAT THEY COULD
BE CATEGORIZED IN THREE KEY
AREAS. O THE FIRST KEY AREA
ONE IS THAT CDA ROUTINELY
BORROW THE RESTRICTED FUNDS
FROM THE PROGRAMS AND TRIGGERED
THE MONIES AS UNRESTRICTED AND
THIS PRACTICE WAS INSTRUMENTAL
TO CBA'S FINANCIAL VIABILITY
SINCE. TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR.
THE SECOND KEY FINDING FROM THE
AUDIT THAT WAS THAT AS OF JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO POINT NINE
MILLION WAS STILL OWED. FIFTY
DELIVERIES ENVIRONMENTAL AND
WORKER SAFETY PROGRAMS FROM ITS
UNRESTRICTED GENERAL PURPOSE
ACCOUNT AND THAT CDA DIDN'T
CURRENTLY HAVE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO REPAY THE AMOUNT
AT THAT TIME. THE THIRD KEY
FINDING WAS A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS RELATED TO INTERNAL
ACCOUNTING PRACTICES- THE
AUDITOR FOUND THAT AROUND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND IN THE MONIES THAT
HAVE BEEN RECEIVED HAVE BEEN
MISSED ALLOCATED BETWEEN THE
ALLOCATED BETWEEN THE ARCTIC
PROGRAM. THE AUDITOR FOUND THAT
CTAS AUDITED FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS FOR EACH FISCAL YEAR
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE AB
INACCURATELY REPORTED THE
MAJORITY OF REVENUES AND NET.
ASSETS AS UNRESTRICTED. THE
AUDITOR FOUND INTERNAL
FINANCIAL REPORTS LACKED
INFORMATION ON WHETHER PROGRAM
FUNDS WERE RESTRICTED AND ALSO
LACKED OTHER INFORMATION TO
ASSESS EACH PROGRAM'S OVERALL
FISCAL CONDITION. AND FINALLY
THE AUDITOR FOUND THAT INTERNAL
ACCOUNTING PRACTICES
SPECIFICALLY HOW REVENUES AND
TRANSFERS WERE DOCUMENTED
CHANGE AROUND FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WHICH RESULTED
IN CERTAIN FINANCIAL REPORTS
BEING INTERNALLY AND
INCONSISTENT. TURNING TO PAGE
SIX OF YOUR HAND OUT CDA THE
CDA BOARD TOOK FOR ACTION IN
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY BEFORE
THE AUDIT BEGAN AND THE AUDITOR
GENERALLY AGREED THAT THEY WERE
APPROPRIATE. SO THESE FOR
ACTIONS THAT WERE ADOPTED
INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING FIRST THE
BOARD SPECIFIED THAT ANY FUTURE
MONIES RECEIVED BY THE C. A.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER SAFETY
PROGRAMS WOULD BE DEPOSITED
INTO SEPARATE RESTRICTED
FINANCIAL ACCOUNTS. THE SECOND
ACTION THE BOARD TOOK WAS TO
INCREASE OVERSIGHT BY REQUIRING
THAT COPIES OF BANK STATEMENTS
RELATED TO THOSE NEW SEPARATE
ACCOUNTS THE PROVIDED TO THE CO
CHAIRS OF CDA IS ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMITTEE. THE THIRD ACTION THE
BOARD TOOK WAS IN THE ABSENCE
OF KIND OF ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
SOURCES THE BOARD COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING FISCAL SUPPORT FOR CD
EIGHT ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS
FROM ITS UNRESTRICTED GENERAL
PURPOSE ACCOUNT- AND THEN THE
FOURTH ACTION OF THE BOARD
TOOK. IS IT SPECIFIED THAT AT
LEAST 10% OF UNENCUMBERED
UNRESTRICTED GENERAL PURPOSE
ACCOUNT MONIES WOULD BE
SATISFIED AT THE END OF EACH
FISCAL YEAR IN ORDER TO RESTORE
THE FUND BALANCES OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER SAFETY
PROGRAM. TURNING TO PAGE SEVEN
THE FINAL PAGE OF YOUR HAND OUT
IN ADDITION TO THOSE ACTIONS
THAT WERE TAKEN BY THE BOARD.
THE AUDITOR RECOMMENDED FIVE
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS FOR CD EIGHT
TO TAKE. THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION WAS FOR CDA TO
TAKE PROACTIVE STEPS TO REVIEW
THE FUNDING RESTRICTIONS TO
ELIMINATE ANY AMBIGUITIES-
RELATED TO THOSE MINING IT'S SO
FOR EXAMPLE PRISON FOR.
RESUMING THAT ANY MONIES
RECEIVED RELATED TO JUDGMENTS
WERE RESTRICTED. THE SECOND
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO IMPROVE
EXTERNAL REPORTING BY HAVING CD
A THAT A REPORT ON HOW
JUDGMENTS MONIES WERE USED. THE
THIRD RECOMMENDATION THE
AUDITOR MADE WAS TO INCREASE
INTERNAL REPORTING TO
LEADERSHIP AND OVERSIGHT BODIES
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON RESTRICTIONS ON
THE USE OF RECEIVED MONEY. THE
FOURTH RECOMMENDATION WAS FOR
CDA TO IMPROVE THEIR ACCOUNTING
PRACTICES IN VERY SPECIFIC WAYS
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
FINANCIAL REPORTS WERE
INTERNALLY CONSISTENT. AND
FINALLY THE AUDITOR RECOMMENDED
IMPROVING INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS BY HAVING COPIES
OF ANY JUDGMENTS BE PROVIDED TO
YOU SEE THE EIGHT ACCOUNTING
DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE A COPY OF THAT AND SO THAT
THEY COULD DOCUMENT MONIES IN
AN APPROPRIATE MANNER INCLUDING
TO TRACK WHETHER OR NOT THE
MONIES HAD ACTUALLY BEEN
RECEIVED. WITHOUT WILL CONCLUDE
OUR COMMENTS WERE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THE NEXT PANEL OF CAN
BEGAN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING. MY NAME IS KEN
SPENCE AND I'M A SENIOR POLICY
ADVISOR AT NEXT IN POLICY
CENTER BASED HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
CONSUMER FINANCE PROTECTION
ISSUES. ALTHOUGH VITAL JUSTICE
POLICY IS NOT MY COURT AREA
NEXTGEN IS A JUSTICE AND EQUITY
CENTER NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
FOUNDED BY TOM DYER FOCUSES ON
IT A DIVERSE ARRAY OF POLICY
AREAS. HEALTH EDUCATION. FOOD
SECURITY ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
TO VOTING RIGHTS AND CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND SO GIVEN OUR FOCUS.
THIS ISSUE REALLY STRUCK A IN
EQUITY AND JUSTICE STANDPOINT.
THIS PUBLIC TAXPAYER MONEY WAS
INTENDED TO DO JUST THAT. TO
PROVIDE EQUITY AND JUSTICE TO
BUY SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITIES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT NEED THIS
TYPE OF SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE
TO GO AFTER THOSE WHO VIOLATE
OUR VINYL PROTECTION LAWS. AND
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES IN HARM'S
WAY. IT IS FUNDS WERE LARGELY
SAYS THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
RANDOM APARTMENT POLLUTION AND
DEGRADATION. AND THAT IS THE
REASON THAT WE ALONG WITH TEN
OTHER APARTMENT ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS. COMPELLED TO
SIGN ONTO A LETTER REQUESTING
BACK DECISIVE AND SWIFT ACTION
BE TAKEN TO HOLD THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HIS MISDEEDS.
WE WANT RESPECT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE TO FOLLOW. WANT TO
SHORTEN THE FOURSOME TRAINEE
FUNDS NO LONGER PATH TO CDA AT.
TO THERE'S A ROBUST
INVESTIGATION IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE THE FULL SCOPE
WHETHER MY FEELINGS IN THEM OUT
OF MONEY THAT WAS MISUSED OR
MISAPPROPRIATED OVER THE YEARS.
THREE IF YOU NEED A REPAIR
MUNICIPAL ALL MONEY THE STOLEN
AND FINALLY. GOING FORWARD. AB
PROHIBITIVE EITHER DISTURBING
OR RECEIVING GRANTS INTENDED
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL FORCING
ENSURING. PLEASE CRITICAL
DOLLARS SHOULD KEEP ON. A WEAK
INTENDED GIVING CA DENTISTRY ON
TRUSTWORTHINESS THE FUNDS
SHOULD INSTEAD BE OVERSEEN BY
RESPONSIBLE GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES. AND GO DIRECTLY TO
THE LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
OFFICES ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS DOING THIS
CRITICAL WORK. IN THE FINAL
THING I LIKE TO SAY. IS THAT AT
A TIME WHEN PUBLIC TRUST IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN SO
UNDERMINE. WHAT WE CAN TO HAVE
HERE **** ONE MORE EXAMPLE OF
ALARMFORCE ORGANIZATION.
FLAGRANTLY IGNORE BOTH THE WILL
OF THE LEGISLATURE. IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF OUR MOST AFFORDABLE
COMMUNITIES. ARE USING
RESOURCES PROVIDED TO HELP
PROTECT OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
FAMILIES. BY METAL MARC. TWO
STATE CHAMPION POLICIES THAT
SUPPORT MASS INCARCERATION. IN
THE WAY OF COMPLETE JUSTICE
REFORM. ANY SYSTEM. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CHURCH. THANK YOU CAN
WE HAVE OUR NEXT PANELIST WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. HI GOOD
MORNING I AM ACTUALLY WARNER
AND I'M A DIRECTING ATTORNEY
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE
TODAY FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WORKS
ALONGSIDE RESIDENTS OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND EAST
COACHELLA VALLEY. MOST OF THE
COMMUNITIES WE WORK WITH
EXPERIENCED SEVERE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION
RESULTING FROM POLLUTING LAND
USES LOCATED WITHIN AND
SURROUNDING THESE COMMUNITIES.
IN MANY CASES THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HARMS CAUSED BY THESE LAND USES
EXCEED LIMITS SET BY LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS AND
OFTEN RESULT FROM LANDOWNERS
AND FACILITY OPERATORS FAILURE
TO TAKE REQUIRED STEPS TO
REDUCE IMPACTS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AND NEARBY HOMES.
AS VIOLATIONS UNDERMINE PUBLIC
HEALTH HOUSING QUALITY AND WELL
BEING AND OUR STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. AND
DEEPEN THE DISPARITIES ALONG
RACE INCOME AND GEOGRAPHIC
LINES THAT SCAR OUR STATE. I'LL
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
EXAMPLES FROM FRESNO FOR WHICH
DISTRICT ATTORNEY INTERVENTION
COULD HAVE CORRECTED
ENVIRONMENTAL VIOLATIONS AND
BENEFITED THE PUBLIC. THE FIRST
EXAMPLE IS THE DARLING
INGREDIENTS MEAT RENDERING
PLANT LOCATED IN THE HEART. OF
THE WEST FRESNO COMMUNITY. WEST
FRESNO IS COMPRISED ALMOST
ENTIRELY OF BLACK LATINO AND
ASIAN AMERICAN RESIDENTS AND
RANKS AMONG THE MOST POLLUTION
BURDEN NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE
STATE UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
EPA'S HOW EMBARRASSED GREAT
TOOL. THE DARLING PLANT IS
LOCATED ACROSS FROM A COMMUNITY
PARK AND YOUR HOMES AND I WAS
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND PROCESSES
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND POUNDS OF MEAT PER DAY.
ODORS FROM ITS OPERATIONS
SATURATE THE AIR IN RESIDENTS
YARDS AND PUBLIC SPACES. INVADE
HOMES THROUGH OPEN WINDOWS IN
EACH FAX SYSTEMS AND BECAUSE
RESIDENTS EXPERIENCING NAUSEA
AND HEADACHES AND STRESS. INTO
MANY OCCASIONS TRUCKS HAVE
LEACHED ANIMAL JUICES AND IT'S
SPELLED AND COVERED ANIMAL
CARCASSES ON THE LOCAL ROADWAYS.
DESPITE THE PLANT SIZE AND
SEVERE IMPACTS ON THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AT THE FACILITY IS
OPERATED FOR FIFTY YEARS
WITHOUT EVER OBTAINING A LAND
USE PERMIT REQUIRED BY THE
LOCAL MUNICIPAL CODE WITHOUT
EVER UNDERGOING ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW. THANKS TO THE
DEDICATION OF A GROUP OF
COMMUNITY LEADERS CALLED
CONCERNED CITIZENS OF WEST
FRESNO DISCOVER THE PLANTS LACK
OF A LAND USE PERMIT AND WHO
FOUGHT FOR MORE THAN FIFTEEN
YEARS TO ADDRESS THE PLANTS
VIOLATIONS. THE PLANT WILL SHUT
DOWN IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
HOWEVER INVESTIGATION AND
ENFORCEMENT BY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE COULD HAVE
SAVED ME AS RESIDENTS COUNTLESS
HOURS. FREED UP NONPROFIT LEGAL
COUNSEL AT LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
TO PURSUE OTHER VIOLATIONS AND
HELP SECURE JUSTICE YEARS
EARLIER. THE SECOND EXAMPLE I
WILL SHARE IS RELATED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AN AMAZON
WAREHOUSE CENTER IN SOUTH
CENTRAL FRESNO I NEARBY HOMES
AND AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN THE
MOST POLLUTION BURDEN CENSUS
TRACT IN THE STATE ACCORDING TO
CALAVERAS SCREEN. DURING THE
FACILITIES AROUND THE CLOCK
MONTHSLONG CONSTRUCTION DUST
CLOUDS FROM CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES COLLUDED RESIDENTS
HOMES TRIGGERING ASTHMA
ATTACKS. AND UNRELENTING NOISE
KEPT RESIDENTS UP AT NIGHT. ONE
RESIDENT WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
WHO LIVES ACROSS FROM THE
DISTRIBUTION CENTER EXPERIENCE
DEFINITELY IN ONE YEAR. SINCE
THE FACILITY INITIATED
OPERATIONS AND MYRIAD OF IMPACT
UNDERMINE RESIDENTS ENJOYMENT
OF THEIR HOMES AND THEIR
HEALTH. FOR EXAMPLE UNABATED
LIGHT SPILLS INTO HOMES FROM
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
OPERATIONS AND INTERRUPT
RESIDENTS SLEEP. KEEP FROM THE
ENORMOUS CONCRETE STRUCTURE
RESULT IN HIGHER LOCAL
TEMPERATURE IS FORCING
RESIDENTS TO RUN THEIR AC'S
HARDER AND PAY EVEN MORE FOR
UTILITIES AND FRESNO IT'S HOT
SUMMERS. TRUCKS SPEED ON LOCAL
ROADS CREATING SAFETY HAZARDS
FOR KIDS WALKING TO THE NEARBY
SCHOOL AND KICKING UP DUST THAT
MAKES IT HARDER FOR RESIDENTS
TO BREEZE. THESE IMPACTS
EXACERBATE THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY POOR PUBLIC
HEALTH OUTCOMES THE COMMUNITY
ALREADY EXPERIENCES. MANY OF
THEM ARE APPARENT VIOLATIONS OF
LOCAL OR STATE ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS. THE WEST FRESNO
DARLING INGREDIENTS PLANT IN
SOUTH CENTRAL FRESNO AMAZON
WAREHOUSE ARE TWO STRIKING
EXAMPLES OF INSTANCES WHERE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY INTERVENTION
COULD PROVIDE PROTECTIONS TO
IMPACTED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHILE ENSURING COMPLIANCE WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS. EXAMPLES
LIKE THIS ABOUND THROUGHOUT THE
INLAND IN RURAL REGIONS IN
WHICH W WORK WE HOPE THAT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TAKES
APPROPRIATE ACTION TO ENSURE
THAT THE INTENT OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ENFORCEMENT
INTRIGUING ACT IS REALIZED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO OUR
PANEL I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
AND I'M GOING TO OPEN IT UP TO-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANTED TO
START WITH THE L. A. AND IF WE
COULD GO BACK TO PAGE SIX OF
YOUR- REPORT. DO WE HAVE ANY
ERA. YES ABSOLUTELY. MEET A
PARTICULAR PART OKAY I IN YOUR
LAST BULLET ON PAGE SIXTY
TALKED ABOUT CTA'S- PROMISED TO
PAY BACK THE FUNDS. IN YOUR
APPROXIMATION HOW LONG WILL IT
TAKE TO PAY BACK THE FUNDS WITH
THE WHAT WHAT WHAT THE LAST
WITH US THERE. IT'S A LITTLE
BIT FOR US A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO TELL
BECAUSE WITH THE INVESTIGATION
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT-
INFORMATION THAT IS PROVIDED
RELATED TO TOTAL AMOUNTS. THAT
ARE AVAILABLE ARE A LITTLE BIT
HARD TO COME BY- I WOULD SAY
THAT. THE KEY FOCUS HERE IS
THAT IT IS UNENCUMBERED AND
UNRESTRICTED AND IT DOES SEEM
LIKE THAT QUITE A FEW. OF THE
MONEY THAT I RECEIVE BY CDA ARE
ACTUALLY RESTRICTED AND SO
WE'VE SEEN ESTIMATES THAT THIS
COULD BE SOMETHING AROUND. YOU
KNOW THE WINDS OF A HUNDRED AND
THOUSANDS YOU KNOW HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS COULD BE
AVAILABLE. PER YEAR AND SO IF
KEEPING IN MIND THAT THE
AUDITOR FOUND THAT THERE WAS
TWO POINT NINE MILLION THAT
MUST BE REPAID THAT'S- QUITE A
FEW YEARS. SO WE'RE TALKING OF
AT LEAST THIRTY YEARS. TO REPAY
THAT IF THEY'RE ABLE TO PAY
THAT BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
YEAR. SO LET'S ASSUME FOR A
SECOND THAT. THEY STARTED
BORROWING FROM RESTRICTIVE
FUNDS BECAUSE- THERE FINANCES
WERE NOT A- ARE NOT ADEQUATE
AND THE WAY THEY WERE SPENDING.
AND SO. AND SO IT SEEMS LIKE
EVEN OF THAT PLAN THAT THEY'RE
NEVER GOING TO HAVE ANY MONEY
AT THE END OF THE YEAR TO REPAY
ANYTHING SOMEBODY HAVE A PLAN
THAT'S AT LEAST THIRTY YEARS IS
ALSO GETS AS MIGHT BE NEVER.
THERE THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
LETTERS THAT. IT THAT IT SEEMS
LIKE THEY CAN PULL. ONE IS- ON
THE EXPENDITURE SIDE MIKE MADAM
CHAIR BROUGHT UP. THE OTHER IS
ONE OF THEIR FUNDS WORTH IS ON
THE MEMBERSHIP DUES. SIDE FOR
EXAMPLE AND SO- IT IS POSSIBLE
CERTAINLY POSSIBLE THAT THE
BOARD COULD CHOOSE TO INCREASE.
DUES FOR EXAMPLE OR A LOOK AT
RAISING REVENUES AND- OTHER
WAYS- AND THOSE FINES FOR THE
MOST PART IF THEY'RE COMING IN
FROM MEMBERSHIP DUES. WOULD BE
A- LESS RESTRICTED THAN YOU
KNOW COMING IN FROM LITIGATION
FOR EXAMPLE- IN. AND THEN I
THINK OF COURSE YOUR FIRST BILL
ELLIOTT BEFORE I MOVE ON TO THE
EASY GROUPS. DOT IT WAS JUST OF
THE SPECIFIC BONTA WE DON'T AND
WE DO NOT KNOW THERE WAS A
MISAPPROPRIATION OF OTHER FUNDS.
HER ACCESS SO- FOR EXAMPLE-
UNDER LIST OF STATE FUNDING-
THE ASSET FORFEITURE FUNDING
THE HIGH TECH FUNDING THOSE ARE
EXAMPLES OF OTHER FUNDING THAT
THEY'RE GETTING AT LEAST FROM
THE STATE LEVEL. THAT WAS NOT
REVIEWED BY THE AUDIT THERE ARE
ALSO PROGRAMS WITHIN CDA THAT
ARE OPERATED- WE'VE HEARD FOR
EXAMPLE RELATED TO WORKER
RECEIVE STATE FUNDING BUT THEY
CAN BE RECEIVING LITIGATION
DOLLARS FROM CASES THAT ARE
EDUCATED LOCALLY AND THEY'RE
GETTING MONEY THAT WAY SO IT
DIDN'T COVER- IT DIDN'T COVER
REVIEW OF ANY. SORRY DIDN'T
COVER AN AUDIT OF HIGH TECH OR
THE ASSET FORFEITURE FUNDS- BUT
THERE MAY BE OTHER FINDS A
SIMILAR TO WORKER SAFETY WHICH
WAS REVIEWED- WHERE THE MONIES
ARE COMING IN LOCALLY OR FROM
SETTLEMENTS THAT. THAT ARE-
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN REVIEWED
EITHER- OKAY AND THEN MAIL MY
LAST QUESTION TO THE ALEJO- USE
YOU GAVE US A LIST OF. A THING
FOR THINGS THAT THE CDA IS
DOING TO TRY TO REFORM ITS WAY.
BUT THERE FIVE ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE AUDIT
THAT THEY HAVE NOT IMPLEMENTED
ARE THEY NOT PLANNING TO
IMPLEMENT YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
CLUE ABOUT THAT. I DO NOT KNOW-
CTAS PROGRESS ON IMPLEMENTING
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY
THE AUTHOR. I THANK YOU WITH I
APPRECIATE THAT I APPRECIATE.
THE LITTLE BIT OF LIGHT THAT
YOU GAVE US ON WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THE FENCE HERE IT'S A
LITTLE FRUSTRATING WE DON'T
HAVE. CDA TO BILLS HAVE SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS DIRECTLY OF
THEM BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION YOU'VE PROVIDED US
OF THE FLOOR- NEXT I WANT TO
TALK TO THE E. J. GROUPS AND I
THINK EITHER. I WOULD NEXT
SENATE LEADERS TO COUNCIL AT
THE NEXT AND SPECIFICALLY- SAID
THAT THE SELLER SHOULD NOT BE
GOING TO CDA AND SO IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE WHAT HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE MORE EFFECTIVE APPROACHES
TO ADDRESSING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
RELATED VIOLATIONS. AND DO YOU
HAVE ANY COLLABORATIVE
APPROACHES WITH ANY DA OFFICES
AND STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE
WORKED IN ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
SO WITH ALL TERM AN ALTERNATIVE
MODEL. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MADAM CHAIR. OF IN
TERMS OF ONE ALTERNATIVE- THAT
MAY BE EFFECTIVE IN GETTING A
POINT WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO- I
JUST WANNA CLARIFY THAT WE'RE%
NOT SUGGESTING THAT THE MONEY
SHOULD NOT GO. TO LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OFFICES OR TO
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS ON
THE GROUND AS IT DOES NOW. BUT
IT SHOULD NOT PASSED THROUGH.
X. ONE OPTION FOR EXAMPLE. IF
IT'S MONEY- YOU KNOW INITIALLY
COMING FROM TOP COUNTY PA. READ
THE PASSAGES YOU CAN DIRECT. TO
THOSE OFFICES OR- ALL RIGHT A
PASSING. PASSING THROUGH. AND
IN TERMS OF- PARTNERSHIP WE'VE
HAD- TERMS OF. ARM I HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT ONE AS
I MENTIONED ON THE BALLOT
JUSTICE NOW MY CORE AREA- BUT
OUT THERE FOLKS ARE TEAMS WHO
WORK VERY CLOSELY IN THIS-
ARENA AND CAN SPEAK TO THAT BUT
ALSO TO MY A COLLEAGUE
ACTUALLY. DEFEATED IMPEACHMENT
ADD TO THAT QUESTION. SURE THE
END THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
YOU KNOW MANY COMMUNITY
BENEFITS ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
ORGANIZATIONS EXIST LIKE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL THAT CAN DO
ENFORCEMENT WORK AND- OR
PARTNER WITH APPROPRIATE LEGAL
ORGANIZATIONS YOU IMPORTANT
FORCE NETWORK SO LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL REPRESENTED CONCERNED
CITIZENS OF WEST FRESNO FOR
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS. DARLING
INGREDIENTS CASE THAT I SHARED
AND- WE'VE ALSO WORKED WITH
RESIDENTS ON THE AMAZON
WAREHOUSE ISSUE BUT IT IS A
RESOURCE ISSUE WERE HAVINGAN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FROM FUNDS
LIKE THESE WOULD BE. REALLY
HELPFUL BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY VIOLATIONS AND- THAT COULD
BE PURSUED AND SHOULD BE
PURSUED I'M AND ONE ADDITIONAL-
SUGGESTION I WOULD OFFER IN
ADDITION. ALONG WITH WHAT CAN
WAS OFFERING ITS POTENTIALLY
ENHANCED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT FUNDS
FLOW TO LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OFFICES. JUST MAKING SURE WE
HAVE A STRONG SYSTEM IN PLACE
TO REALLY ENSURE THOSE FUNDS
ARE BEING USED AND- THE WAY
THAT COMMUNITIES WANT THEM TO
BE USED IN AND SEE THEIR
HIGHEST VALUE OF THESE. THANK
YOU. FOR THAT THANK AS THERE I
WILL SAY WHEN YOU WERE
DESCRIBING THE- DATA CARCASSES
AND THE SMELLS THAT HAD SOME
FLASHBACKS TO WHEN I WAS
TEACHING HIGH SCHOOL AND- WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF MEAT RENDERING
PLANTS NOT TOO FAR INTO THAT
SMELL- WAS SOMETHING WE HAD TO
CONTEND WITH ON A REGULAR
BASIS. AS WELL AND SO. ON THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK TO HELP. TO
HELP THE COMMUNITY INVEST
THOUGH IT'S- IT WAS ALWAYS HARD
TO TRY TO BE A TEACHER TO
STUDENT ON WHEN THAT WAS
LINGERING IN THE SUMMER- SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT WORK- MY L.
A. PAUL I. HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR ON OF ITS- OR OR
THE I DON'T IS THAT WE HAVE
HERE. DO WE KNOW- IF ANY OF
THESE PHONES WERE BEING USED
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES OUT
THERE ARE YOU KNOW ARM. NO NO.
W. WITH LARGEST PANEL. OFFICE
THINK THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WOULDN'T BE TO THE- TO
SPEAK TO- IF THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT MADAM CHAIR WAS INTERESTED
AND I THINK THE KEY THING FROM
THE AUDIT WHAT IS THAT HE'S
DOLLARS WHICH WERE RESTRICTED
WERE BEING USED- BY THAT BUT
FOR THEIR GENERAL FUND THEIR
UNRESTRICTED PURPOSES AND SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU DESCRIBE
WAS CERTAINLY FALL WITHIN THAT
CATEGORY OF UNRESTRICTED-
DOLLARS WHERE YOU WOULD WANT.
ABSOLUTE FLEXIBILITY. YES I
THINK IT IS REALLY IT REALLY
PERPLEXED- TO HAVE. AN AGENCY
OR GROUP OF. APART PUBLIC
SAFETY INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE
MISS YOU SEEN FUNDS THAT ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO KEEP A PUBLIC
HEALTH- AND- WELL WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE ANSWERS AND WE DON'T
HAVE CD HERE- IT DOES BEG THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER PRIORITIES
ARE AT. WITH THAT I DON'T KNOW
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THIS PANEL. MISTER
JONES SAWYER. THANK. EXCUSE ME-
I RECEIVED A LETTER FROM THE
LOS ANGELES FEDERATION LABOR
WHICH BASICALLY I KNOW WHEN TO
TALK ABOUT MORE OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL- FUNDING THAT WAS
GIVEN BUT THERE WAS ALSO A
CONCERN ABOUT THE CDA WORKING
ON WORKING CONDITIONS WAGE
THEFT AND- UNION BUSTING THE
REASON THIS IS IMPORTANT-
ESPECIALLYIN THE DISTRICTS
THAT I COME FROM- WE HAVE A
LARGE MANUFACTURING IN IN SOUTH
LA. AND THE SURROUNDING AREA.
AND WE DURING COLD IT. THERE
WERE EMPLOYERS THAT DID NOT.
FOLLOW THE COBIT PROTOCOL ARE
HAD NONE AT ALL. PEOPLE DIED. A
LOT OF PEOPLE DIED BECAUSE OF
EMPLOYERS WHO DID NOT EVEN
CONSIDER THAT THE WORKING TODAY
CONDITIONS THAT THEY'RE
INDIVIDUALS WERE IN- COULD NOT
ONLY CAUSE HARM COULD CAUSE
DEATH. I DON'T REMEMBER. THE
DA'S OFFICE LIKE GOING IN AND
REALLY PROSECUTING PEOPLE WHO
IN SOME WAYS HAVE COMMITTED
SOME OF THE MOST HEINOUS CRIMES
AYE I THINK YOU COULD POSSIBLY
DO IS ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET COBIT
NINETEEN AND DIE. BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO KEEP THE
MANUFACTURING PLANTS GOING AND
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS MOSTLY
LATINO. AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE WELFARE
AND SAFETY I WOULD THINK THIS
WOULD BE A PERFECT PLACE THAT'S
THE DA'S OFFICE WOULD PLAY IN.
AND I DON'T REMEMBER A WHOLE
LOT OF ACTIVITY NOT ONLY MY
DISTRICT BUT BUT STATEWIDE SO I
I'M KIND OF CURIOUS THAT IT
MENTIONS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PORTION OF IT. BUT ALSO READ
THAT THERE'S SOME THINGS IN
YOUR ABOUT MOM WORKER SAFETY
AND THE LABOR AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE IT CAN YOU DO YOU
KNOW WHAT THE BREAKDOWNIS OR
R. OR IS THIS THAT YOU WERE
MENTIONING OTHER POTS. IS THIS
ANOTHER POT THAT WE NEED TO DO
AN AUDIT ON OR IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT'S KIND OF IN
THAT TWO POINT NINE MILLION-
CAN ANYBODY ANSWER. THAT THANK
ANALYSTS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ALICE OFFICE SO THE AUDITOR
THAT WAS HIRED TO DO THE
EXTERNAL AUDIT REVIEWED THE CDA
PROGRAMS IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ARENA AS WELL AS THE WORKER
HEARING OUT SO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JIM SIR WHAT YOU BROUGHT UP- IN
TERMS OF OUR HAND OUT WHEN WE
WERE ASKED TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF STATE FUNDING. WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO FIND- EXAMPLES
IN IN RECENT YEARS OF STATE
FUNDS GOING TO THE WORKER
SAFETY PROGRAMS THE SAME WAY
THAT MONIES WENT ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS. THAT
BEING SAID IN THE REVIEW OF THE
AUDIT THERE WERE MONIES THAT
WERE GOING TO THE WORKER SAFETY
PROGRAMS AND SO THEY ARE LIKELY
COMING FROM JUDGMENTS AND
SETTLEMENTS. THAT ARE BEING
PURSUED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- AND
THE FUNDS ARE FLOWING IN THAT
WAY AND SO. ON THE FINAL PIECE
OF YOUR QUESTION THE TWO POINT
NINE MILLION AND- THAT IS- IS A
COMBINATION OF WHAT IS OWED TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IT COUNTS. AS
WELL AS TO THE WORKER SAFETY
ACCOUNTS IF YOU LIKE A
PARTICULAR BREAKDOWN I THINK WE
HAVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
OFFICE ON IT BECAUSE I JUST
DON'T HAVE THAT READILY AT MY
FINGERTIPS AT THIS MOMENT BUT
WE CAN. CERTAINLY WORK WITH
YOUR STAFF TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION AND I WOULD LOVE.
TO SEE A BREAKOUT M. IN
ADDITION TO IT I MEAN IT'S HARD
TO HAVE A FULL DISCUSSION. WHEN
YOU DON'T HAVE THE OTHER SIDE
HERE. AND I. DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE BUT I I'VE ONLY HAD
LIMITED CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
ABOUT THIS WITH CDA. AT THE-
MMHM I. THERE WERE ABOUT
LEADING. AND THINGS THAT NATURE
BUT IT. IS THERE MUST'VE BEEN
SOME. BACK TO YOUR DEPARTMENT
ABOUT WHY. THEY FEEL THAT. THEY
MAY HAVE SPENT THE MONIES IN A
CERTAIN WAY THEY CAN CAN YOU
COMMENT ON THAT OR ARE WE IN
THE SAME POSITION OF LITIGATION
YOU DON'T WANT TO. SAY ANYTHING
THAT COULD BE USED. FOR OR
AGAINST THEM- GOOD LUCK I.
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR POSITION
IS REALLY. SENATE ONLY AGAIN
WHAT THE L. A. L. JUST JUST TO
MAKE IT CLEAR FOR THOSE FOR
LISTENING WE DID NOT DO THE
AUDITS- THE AUDIT WAS CONDUCTED
BY A PRIVATE COMPANY- CALL
COMING IN MORRIS AND SO. I WE
WERE NOT AWARE OF WHAT
CONVERSATIONS MAY HAVE TAKEN
PLACE BETWEEN CA AND HAVING A
MORRIS- WHICH IS KIND OF THE
TRADITIONAL RELATIONSHIP- WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FEEDBACK
TO AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS- WE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH CDA AND
STATE DEPARTMENTS AS WE WERE
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS CANNOT TO
KIND OF HELP INFORM THAT- I
WOULD SAY THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS WERE FOR FALL-
BUT THE FACT THAT THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION MAKES THINGS A
LITTLE BIT MORE CHALLENGING IN
TERMS OF WHAT INFORMATION CAN
OR CANNOT BE SHARED. OKAY THE
THANK YOU IT IS IT IS A-
DIFFICULT GETTING GETTING SOME
FEEDBACK FROM THE OTHER SIDE
AND I HOPE THAT WE DO WE GET
SOMETHING BACK TO THE WEEKEND
OBVIOUSLY RESOLVE THIS- BECAUSE
WHAT WHEN I'M LEVY WITHIN MY
STATEMENT AS A DISS WE NEED TO
BE A- TO DO THEIR JOB- I LIVE
NEAR THE BOTTOM MY DISTRICT IS
WHAT IS. CLASSICALLY CALLED THE
CORRUPT CRESCENT AND THERE
CITIES IN WHICH WE NEED TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO
GO AHEAD BECAUSE THERE'S-
THERE'S FINANCIAL MALFEASANCE
THAT'S GOING ON IN. EPIC
PROPORTIONS- WHERE D. THE
MONIES THAT ARE. DEBT MAY BE
STOLEN IS PROBABLY EQUAL TO OR
NEAR WHAT. THEIR BUDGET IS AND-
AND SO WHAT THEY NEED
PROTECTION. AND THEN THEY NEED
TO HAVE THE DA'S OFFICE-
DIRECTOR LIKE IN MY AREA THINGS
TO POLITICAL INTEGRITY UNIT
PUBLIC INTEGRITY UNIT THE NEED
TO GO IN THERE AND DO THOSE
TYPE OF. INVESTIGATIONS SO THAT
WE CAN KEEP GOVERNMENT HONEST
AND SO- I WOULD I WOULD HOPE
THAT. WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN GET
THAT KIND OF ASSURANCE BECAUSE
IT IT IS PROBLEMATIC ON A LOT
OF DIFFERENT LEVELS. AND-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN. WE CAN GET
BEYOND THIS BUT THIS IS PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT THAT WE NEED TO
INVESTIGATE SO I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU CHAIR FOR BRINGING
THIS TO OUR ATTENTION. THANK
YOU AND AGAIN CDA WAS INVITED
UP THE- DECLINE TO PARTICIPATE
BECAUSE OF- THAT OCCASION
ISSUES POTENTIALLY- AND SO
WHILE IT IS- INCOMPLETE PICTURE
THAT WE ARE GETTING A STILL I
STILL THOUGHT THAT IT MERITED A
DISCUSSION WITH WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE MR STONE. THANK
YOU IN AN AND I THINK IT DOES.
BUT BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
DISTINGUISH HERE BETWEEN CDA
WAS ORGANIZATION AND- LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND THEIR
OFFICES BECAUSE AS FAR AS I
KNOW. WITH THIS. AUDIT THE
pIMPLICATED THIS IS THE
ORGANIZATION CDA. WHICH SITS IN
AN INTERESTING POSITION IN THIS
IS NOT THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
SEEN THIS THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME THAT THIS THAT THINGS LIKE
THIS HAVE HAPPENED WHERE. WE
HAVE. A PRIVATE ORGANIZATION.
THAT IS GETTING. PUBLIC MONEY
BUT HAS CONFLICTING OBLIGATIONS
WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION AND I
SUBMIT THAT THIS IS PRETTY
INDICATIVE OF SOME SIGNIFICANT
CULTURAL PROBLEMS WITHIN CDA
WHERE THEY BLITHELY TAKE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE PUBLIC
MONIES COMING IN BORROW FROM
THOSE ACCOUNTS TO BE USED FOR
OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT THEY
THEMSELVES CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN AND WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS A POLITICAL
ORGANIZATION. THAT ENGAGES
POLITICALLY ACROSS THE STATE
AND ENGAGES IN ADVOCACY FOR
SPECIFIC POSITIONS SO ONE HAS
TO ASSUME WITHOUT OTHER
INFORMATION THAT MONEY IS BEING
BORROWED FOR FROM LEGITIMATE
ACCOUNTS TO PERFORM SPECIFIC
SERVICES GIVEN TO THEM PUBLIC
MONIES GIVEN TO THEM TO THEN
PERFORM MORE OF PRIVATE
ORGANIZATION. ACTIVITIES THE
LOBBYING THE POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES AND OTHER THINGS
THIS IS CLASSIC
MISAPPROPRIATION OF FUNDS THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN ORGANIZATIONS
ORGANIZATIONS. AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE RESPONSE THAT THEY HAVE
DONE SO FAR WITH THE AUDITOR
POINTING OUT THAT CDA HAS TAKEN
CERTAIN STEPS THAT TO FOLLOWS
THE SAME PATTERN WHERE IT'S OH
MY GOSH WE FOUND SOMETHING
WRONG HERE'S WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO WHICH IS AS MINIMAL AS
THEY THINK THEY CAN GET AWAY
WITH. IN ORDER TO RECOVER THE
MONEY IS THE PROBLEM FOR US
THOUGH IS THIS IS SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC DOLLARS THREE MILLION.
OF MISAPPROPRIATED FUNDS. AND A
SEEMINGLY VERY CAVALIER
ATTITUDE TOWARDS THAT
MISAPPROPRIATION SO THAT'S WHY
IT IN WHEN WE HAVE SEEN THIS
BEFORE IN OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT IS CLEARLY A CULTURAL.
PROBLEM THAT SHOULD LEAD TO
SOME SIGNIFICANT SHAKE UP NOT
JUST. MINOR CHANGING OF
POLICIES AND A COMMITMENT TO
PAY BACK MONEY THEY HAVE IS THE
AUTHOR POINT OR IS THAT ELLIE-
POINTS OUT. OTHER WAYS TO RAISE
MONEY. TO REMEDY THIS BUT THE
FACT THAT THEY DON'T SEEM
INTERESTED IN COMING UP WITH A
SERIOUS WAY OF REMEDYING IT AND
JUST SORT OF PAYING OFF IT AS
THEY CAN. FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THAT SHOWS TO ME A LACK OF
SERIOUSNESS AND YEAH THAT'S NOT
JUST. LOOKING AT THIS
ORGANIZATION BUT HAVING SEEN
THE SAME KIND OF ORGANIZATION.
REACH THESE PROBLEMS IN IN THE
PAST AND SO THEIR PATTERNS OR
THE SAME AS WE HAVE SEEN SO I
THINK THEY HAVE SOME VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT INTERNAL. PROBLEMS
THAT THEY NEED TO OWN UP TO.
AND DEAL WITH. ACCORDING TO THE
AUDIT REPORT THAT THE L. A. WAS
WAS LOOKING AT THEY'VE BEEN
HAVING SERIOUS FINANCIAL
PROBLEM SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR. AND SHOWS. CHOSE TO DEAL
WITH THAT BY BORROWING. FROM
PUBLIC DOLLARS TO PAY FOR OTHER
ACTIVITIES. THIS IS SIGNIFICANT
WE PROBLEMATIC AS A MISUSE OF
FUNDS MISAPPROPRIATION OF FUNDS
AND A REAL PROBLEM AGAIN
POINTED TO SOME VERY KIND OF A
CAVALIER ATTITUDE A INTERNAL
CULTURAL PROBLEM WITH RESPECT
TO HOW THEY- LOOK AT MONEY HOW
THEY WANT TO MANAGE MONEY AND
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO THEM
CLEARLY WHAT'S NOT IMPORTANT TO
THEM. FOR THE PURPOSES FOR
WHICH THE MONEY WAS RECEIVED BY
CDA AT WHAT WAS IMPORTANT TO
THEM WERE THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
THEY DIVERTED THOSE FUNDS TO
THAT THEY LOANED THE FUNDS TO
WITHOUT ANY PLAN. FOR PAYING
THEM BACK. AGAIN CLASSIC KIND
OF INTERNAL. EITHER WHILE
CULTURAL PROBLEMS WITH RESPECT
TO ME COULD BE INCOMPETENCE BUT
I THINK THIS WAS A PLANNED WAY
BUT BUT BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
PLAN FOR COMING OUT FROM
UNDERNEATH THIS THERE'S SOME
REAL STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS THERE
SO WHAT CAN WE DO I THINK WE
CAN TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE THIS RECEIVED
THE MONEY AND WE CAN CHANGE
THAT BY ENSURING THAT THE MONEY
GOES DIRECTLY TO THE RECIPIENT
ORGANIZATIONS RATHER THAN
FEEDING IT THROUGH AN
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS SHOWN.
THAT THEY WILL USE THAT MONEY
FOR PURPOSES WHICH GO COUNTER
TO WHAT THE IT THAT INVESTMENT
IN THAT AGENCY WAS IN AND I CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY THE STATE
DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO CDA WOULD EXPECT
THEM AND TRUST THEM TO GET THAT
MONEY OUT TO THE LOCAL
PROSECUTING OFFICES FOR BEST
RESULTS AND DO THAT KIND OF
TRAINING. BUT THIS IS BEEN A
SYSTEMIC ISSUE WITHIN THAT
ORGANIZATION SINCE AT LEAST TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR THAT THAT
THEY HAVE HAD HAVE NOT REPORTED
IT DID NOT HAVE APPROPRIATE
INTERNAL CONTROLS. SO HOW MUCH
CAN WE TRUST THAT ORGANIZATION
TO CLEAN UP ITS ACT AND TO TAKE
APPROPRIATE STEPS. I DON'T
KNOW. BUT WE ARE THE ONES DOING
THE OVERSIGHT WE ARE THE ONES
THAT HAVE THE ABILITY TO ENSURE
THAT MONEY GOES WHERE IT IS
SUPPOSED TO GO. BYE MORE DIRECT
ALLOCATIONS AS AS WAS
MENTIONED. BY SOME OF THE
WITNESSES AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING. THAT THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD BE TAKING A LOOK AT. AND
AS A- POTENTIAL MECHANISM FOR
ENSURING THAT WE DO NOT LEAVE
WITHIN. A SUSPECT ORGANIZATION
THE TEMPTATION TO CONTINUE TO
TAKE MONEY AND NOT BE
RESPONSIBLE UNTIL THEY COME UP
WITH THE REAL PLAN. TO PAY THIS
MONEY BACK AND PAY IT BACK. NOW
THAT THAT'S JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE
FOR THE SPECTER OF THIS MONEY
JUST CAVALIERLY SAY WELL WE'LL
PAY IT BACK OVER THIRTY YEARS
AS WE GET. REVENUES TO BE ABLE
TO PAY BACK. NOT ACCEPTABLE
THEY NEED TO COME UP WITH A
BETTER PLAN FOR THAT. SO THIS
IS TO ME. AN INDICATION OF A
VERY UNHEALTHY ORGANIZATION
WITH SOME SIGNIFICANT. CULTURAL
ISSUES ON HOW IT'S MANAGED AND
A REAL CAVALIER ATTITUDE
TOWARDS ITS RESPONSIBILITY TO
SAY HOW IT SPENDS PUBLIC
DOLLARS. AND THAT'S WHERE I
THINK WE SHOULD BE TAKING A
LOOK AT. AT OTHER MECHANISMS
I'M NOT SURE HOW WE DO THAT AT
THIS POINT. YEAH BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK THAT
THAT WE HAVE STATE. YOU TO TAKE
SOME. ACTIONS ON. AIR AND DO
SOME INVESTIGATION AS TO WHERE
THOSE MONIES ARE COMING FROM
HOW WE CAN ENSURE THAT THERE'S
SOME DIRECT ALLOCATION. AS WE
LOOK AT THAT POTENTIAL
MALFEASANCE IN A PRIVATE
ORGANIZATION. WHO AND THEY THEY
COULD HAVE BEEN HERE THEY COULD
PROVIDE INFORMATION WE DON'T
KNOW THAT THERE IS A CRIMINAL
CASE. THERE'S A JUST AN
INVESTIGATION THAT'S GOING ON
SO THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT SURE
WHAT WHAT THEY'RE DOING OR HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE. BUT THERE IS
INDICATION THAT THIS IS VERY
VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM AB
MISAPPROPRIATION OF. A LOT OF
MONEY. SO I APPRECIATE BUT I'M
SURE THAT YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD AND WE'LL HAVE TO SEE
HOW THIS GOES. THANK YOU MR
STONE- AND- YOU KNOW IT THE
WITH WITH ANY TO PAY THE MONEY
BACK NOW. BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
ENOUGH BECAUSE IN THE
MISAPPROPRIATION OF THE DOLLARS
THEY WEREN'T DOING THEIR JOB TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH. ARE
PROTECT THE EMPLOYEES AND SO I
THINK WE TAKE THAT INTO INTO
ACCOUNT THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT
IS OWED AND IT DOES BEG THE
QUESTION IF PUBLIC FUNDS SHOULD
BE GOING TO A PRIVATE
ORGANIZATION. OF THAT HAS A
QUARTER LIKE YOU SAY THAT. YOU
KNOW TWO THOUSAND FOR AT LEAST
SEVENTEEN YEARS ABOUT ALSO THAT
ENGAGES IN A LOT OF POLITICAL
ACTIVITY WHICH IS WHAT WHAT
TROUBLED ME I DO NOT WANT TO
SEE PUBLIC FUNDS BEING USED FOR
POLITICAL- CAMPAIGNS OUT THERE
WE KNOW THAT THEIR AGGRESSIVELY
ENGAGE IN THOSE CAMPAIGNS. IN
BIG DOLLARS A MONTH I EVERY
CYCLE- AND I DO ALSO HAVE THE
QUESTION OF WHY TOOK SEVENTEEN
YEARS TO. TO UNCOVER THE
SITUATION SINCE IT'S BEEN GOING
ON FOR AT LEAST ALONG WITH THIS
BUT THIS FUND AND THEY DID ASK
THE QUESTION OF WHAT OTHER
FUNDS- AND SO I DO THINK AS- AS
THE LEGISLATURE WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO
TO. ENSURE THE FUNDS ARE BEING
USED APPROPRIATELY AND THAT
THERE IS ACCOUNTABILITY AT THIS
ORGANIZATION- AND I- A- WONDER.
REALLY WHY UNTIL OF. IN
ANALYSTS BUT I DO I THINK THE
L. A. L. THEY DID GIVE US A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A PICTURE OF
HOW THIS ORGANIZATION WORKS I
AND I WANT TO THANK THE FOLKS
TO HELP UNCOVER THIS- AND HAVE
CONTINUED TO SHED A LIGHT ON
THIS INTO THE ADVOCACY GROUPS
UP UNDERGROUND JUST I THANK YOU
FOR. YOUR CONTINUED WORK IN THE
SPACE. OF THEIR OF THEIR NUMBER
QUESTIONS. IN THIS- FOR THIS
PANEL AND THEN MOVE ON TO OUR
SECOND PANEL. MADAM CHAIR MADAM
CHAIR I HAVE A- I HAVE A QUICK
RESPONSE FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES QUESTION KIANA JONES
SAWYER IS QUESTION ABOUT THE
PERFORATED YES I AM THE
STATURE- SO IN REGARDS TO THE
TWO POINT NINE MILLION. ABOUT A
THIRD ABOUT ONE TO ONE POINT
ONE MILLION IS RELATED TO
WORKER SAFETY. WORKER SAFETY
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU THAT'S
HELPFUL. THANK YOU. AND SO AS
WE MOVE INTO OUR SECOND PANEL
THAT PANEL WE ARE GOING TO BE
HEARING DIRECTLY FROM A COUPLE
OF DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ANYTHING
AND GOES TO THE POINT OF THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE THEY'RE
GONNA STATION WE HAVE
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
WHO ARE OUT THERE DOING SOME
SOME MARKET WANT TO KEEP THE
KEEP THAT DISTINCTION SEPARATE.
I AND SO WE WILL BE NOW LOOKING
AT OUR SECOND PANEL WITH THIS
AT THE TIME RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION STRATEGIES IN VARIOUS
COUNTIES. APPLE POLICY WISE AND
BUDGET WISE THE STATE HAS BEEN
MOVING IN DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
AND SO WE WILL BE HEARING FROM.
MY APOLOGIES FIVE DIFFERENT
PANELISTS TODAY. WE HAVE
CAITLYN ONLY A LITTLE IS THE
ANALYSTS OFFICE DATA BACK THEN-
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY TRYING FOREVER
TORY RIVER SALAS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
YEAH JUDGE PETER ESPINOSA
DIRECTOR OF L. A. COUNTY OFFICE
OF THEIR VERSIONS AND REENTRY.
AND THEN AS THE MARTIN DIRECTOR
OF RE ENTRY SERVICES FOR IT L.
A. COUNTY OFFICE OF EVERY
SCENARIO TRAIN I WILL ASK YOU
TO THE PALACE TO JUST GO AND
ORDER S. AYE YOU'RE LISTED IN
THE AGENDA AND YOU COULD JUST
GO ONE AFTER. ANOTHER NOT WAY
FOR US TO Q. U. UNTIL WE MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA CAITLIN O'NEILL
WITH THE L. A. O. I WILL BE
SHARING THE SCREEN SO YOU CAN
SEE MY HAND OUT. SO YOU SHOULD
SEE A HAND OUT- ALL THE
SENTENCING DIVERSION AND
REENTRY PROGRAMS- AND IT'S
AVAILABLE- ALSO AVAILABLE ON
OUR WEBSITE UNDER THE
PUBLICATIONS HAVE AS WELL AS ON
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
WHERE YOU ACCESS THE AGENDA FOR
FOLKS THE FOLLOWING ALONG
NICELY. AND IT'S GOING TO THE
FIRST PAGE- JUST A QUICK
OVERVIEW OF MY PRESENTATION I
WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE- A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF SELECTED RECENT
STATE POLICY CHANGES AND
FUNDING THAT SUPPORT
RESENTENCING OF PEOPLE TO
REDUCE SENTENCES DIVERSION
PROGRAMS WHICH TECH TYPICALLY
PROVIDE. REHABILITATION
SERVICES IN LIEU OF
INCARCERATION- AND REENTRY
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT SERVICES TO PEOPLE
TRANSITIONING FROM
INCARCERATION TO THE COMMUNITY.
IN ON PAGE TWO- BEGINS THE LIST
OF SELECTED POLICY CHANGES-
WHICH STARTS WITH PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN. WHICH WAS APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. AND RECLASSIFIED
CERTAIN NON SERIOUS NONVIOLENT
DRUG POSSESSION AND THEFT
RELATED CRIMES FROM FELONIES TO
MISDEMEANORS AND ALSO ALLOWED
FOR RESENTENCING OF FOLKS HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN CONVICTED OF
THOSE CRIMES. AND THE MEASURE
REQUIRES THAT 65% OF THE STATE
SAVINGS RESULTING FROM THE
SENTENCING CHANGES AT SO
LARGELY- THAT SAVINGS FROM
STATE. THE REDUCTION IN THE
STATE PRISON POPULATION BE
DIRECTED TO THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS FOR
GRANTS THE PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT AND DIVERSION
PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND
SENSE LEGISLATION THAT WAS.
PASSED OUT IN TWENTY FIFTEEN-
ADDED SOME ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS TO THAT FUNDING AS
SUCH AS REQUIRING THAT BCC
DISTRICT DISTRIBUTE THE GRANTS
AND COMPETITIVE PROCESS AND
PRIVATE PAADISE CERTAIN.
PROGRAMS IN ADDITION TO WHAT
PROPERTY SEVEN REQUIRED SUCH
AS- PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE.
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. I'M AND
THEN TO DATE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED TO THE PROGRAM-AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ASSUMES
THAT AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION WILL BE
PROVIDED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THE NEXT CATEGORY
OR THE- THAT YEAH THE NEXT
CATEGORY OF CHANGES HAS BEEN
RECENT EXPANSIONS TO- COURTS AT
THE READY TO RE SENTENCE JAIL
AND PRISON INMATES AND- THAT
EXPANSION WAS ACT CREATED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH- SOME
BUDGET LEGISLATION- AND ALLOW
COURTS TO CONSIDER POST
CONVICTION FACTORS SUCH AS
INMATES DISCIPLINARY RECORDS
ARE PROGRAMS THEY PARTICIPATE
IN MODERN CARS ARE RATED. IN
DETERMINING WHETHER TO REDUCE
AN INMATE'S SENTENCE UPON
RECOMMENDATION BY A PRISON OR
JAIL ADMINISTRATOR. AND THE
BUDGET IN THAT YOU'RE ALSO
PROVIDED SOME ONGOING RESOURCES
FOR CDC ARE TO IDENTIFY-
INMATES AND PROPOSE THEM TO THE
COURTS FOR RESENTENCING. AND
THEN- ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION
THAT YEAR EXPANDED THE BILL-
EXPANDED TO DISTRICT ATTORNEYS-
THE ABILITY TO RECOMMEND
INMATES THE COURTS FOR
RESENTENCING UNDER THIS PROCESS.
LIVING ON TO PAGE THREE- THERE
WERE A COUPLE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES RELATED TO MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION ALSO IN-
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE FIRST WAS-
LEGISLATION THAT AUTHORIZED A
TRIAL COURT JUDGES TO GRANT PRE
TRIAL DIVERSION IN MISDEMEANOR
OR FELONY CASES IN WHICH- THE
JUDGE DETERMINES THAT THE
DEFENDANT'S MENTAL ILLNESS- WAS
A SIGNATURE SIGNIFICANT FACTOR
IN THE COMMISSION AND THE-
DEFENSE. I'M UNDER THAT PROCESS
DEFENDANTS. RECEIVE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR UP TO TWO YEARS
AND UPON SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION
OF THE PROGRAM HAVE THEIR
CHARGES DISMISSED- ALSO IN THAT
YEAR THAT. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT- PROVIDED A
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION FROM
THE GENERAL FUND ON A ONE TIME
BASIS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS TO CONTRACT THE
COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH DIVERSION
PROGRAMS FOR DEFENDANTS.
CHARGED WITH FELONIES
SPECIFICALLY THAT ARE LIKELY TO
BE FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL AND SO THAT NEEDS FUNDS
ESSENTIALLY CAN THINK OF THEM
AS SUPPORTING A SUBSET- OF. OF
PEOPLE DIVERTED UNDER THE
CHAPTERS CHAPTER THIRTY FOUR
AND ONE OH FIVE LEGISLATION-
BECAUSE THAT INCLUDED A FELONY
AND MISDEMEANORS AS WELL AS
FELONIES WHERE IS THAT ONE
HUNDRED MILLION IS SPECIFICALLY
FOR. FOLKS LIKE WOULD BE FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AND-
CHARGED WITH A FELONY. I AM
ALSO IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN-
BUDGET ACT THE WHAT IS KNOWN AS
THE ADULT REENTRY GRANT WAS
CREATED- WITH INITIAL FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND-
ALLOCATION FOR THE SEC TO
PROVIDE COMPETITIVE GRANTS. TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO. FIND REENTRY SERVICES
INCLUDING RENTAL ASSISTANCE FOR
PEOPLE COMING OUT OF STATE
PRISON. AND THAT IT SAID TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY ACT AT BUDGET
ACT PROVIDED AT THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION I'M GOING GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROGRAM.
MOVING ON TO PAGE FOUR- THE IT.
AB THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT ALSO INCLUDED
FUNDING FOR DIVERSION OF YOUTH
FROM THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND KNOWN AS THE YOUTH
RANCH AT THE THREE ENTRY-
EXCUSE ME- AT. IT ANOTHER GRANT
PROGRAM- WHERE AT DIVERTING
CHIU FROM YOUTH FROM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM EXCUSE
ME- AND THAT WAS THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION A MILLION AND ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANTS ADMINISTERED
BY THE SEC TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND TRIBES- AND THAT WAS-
FINDING WAS THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- WAS APPROPRIATE IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET ACT FOR
THE PROGRAM AND THAT WAS
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND SUPPORT. ALSO
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY- THE
BUDGET PROVIDED FUNDING FOR SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY. A FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
A DIVERSION PROGRAM OPERATED BY
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
AND THEN FINALLY THE LAST- SO I
CHANGE I WOULD. WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT HERE TODAY IS RELATED
TO MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION WHICH
IS QUITE RECENT-IT WAS A
LEGISLATION APPROVED IN TWENTY
TWENTY- THAT AUTHORIZED TRIAL
COURT JUDGES CHOPPER DIVERSION
TO DEFENDANTS IN MISDEMEANOR
CASES OVER THE OBJECTION OF
PROSECUTORS- AGAIN IF. A
DEFENDANT'S PARTICIPATE IN- AND
COMPLY WITH THE TERMS SET BY
THE JUDGE- DATE. WILL HAVE
THEIR CHARGES DISMISSED. AND
THAT IS THE END OF THE PREPARED
COMMENTS I HAVE AND WILL PASS
IT ON TO THE NEXT ANALYSTS AND
HAPPY TO TAKE. QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU. SO
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING- I'M
DINA BACK IN DISTRICT ATTORNEY
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. I AM
VERY HAPPY TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ABOUT- SHRINKING OUR
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM AND
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
ALSO TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
EFFORTS THAT WE HAVE UNDERTAKEN
TO. REDUCE RECIDIVISM- IT'S NO
SECRET THAT IN THE UNITED
STATES HAS THE HIGHEST
INCARCERATION RATE IN THE WORLD.
AND AS PROSECUTORS WE ARE THE
GATE KEEPERS OF THE LEGAL JEFF
IF WITH THEM SO THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO USE OUR
LIMITED RESOURCES THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES THAT WE ARE
CONTRACTED WITH. TO WISELY USE
THEM TO PROMOTE NOT ONLY PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT ALSO TO REDUCE HARM.
AND THE OBJECTIVES THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE DISCUSSING TODAY
ARE OFTEN BEST SERVED BY
KEEPING PEOPLE ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO COMMIT LOW LEVEL OFFENSIVE
OUT OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. BY USING DIVERSION AND
OTHER ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION SO I LIFTED UP ON
MY FLIGHT A NUMBER. OF PROGRAMS
AND STRATEGIES THAT WE'VE USED
IN MY OFFICES THAT ARE USED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS WELL- IN
THE LIMITED TIME THAT WE HAVE
TODAY I WON'T TRY TO HIGHLIGHT
ALL OF THEM- CERTAINLY IF
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT I DON'T
MENTION SPECIFICALLY- I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO TAKE. ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT HER WHEN THE APPROPRIATE.
TIME KIND. SO COULD HAVE THE
NEXT FLIGHT PLEASE. THE FIRST
ONE THAT I LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT.
ARE TWIST JEFF TO HER PROGRAM
IN SHRINKING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM ONE OF THE
PLACES THAT- I LIKE TO THINK
ABOUT STARTING IS WITHOUT YOU.
BECAUSE CERTAINLY ARGUES- WE'VE
ALL HEARD ABOUT THE PIPELINE
THAT LEADS OUR KIDS FROM SCHOOL
TO PERFORM AND WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE ALTERNATIVES THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE TO ARGUES THAT. WE
CAN BREAK THAT PIPELINE-
ENCONTRABAN COUNTY WE APPLIED
FOR AND WERE AWARDED TO BE A
FIFTY GRANT OF A MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THAT WE COULD
ESTABLISH A JUVENILE DIVERSION
WE FILING PROGRAM. I DIVERSION
PROGRAM IS THE FIRST- IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. WE HAVE PARTNERED
WITH A COMMUNITY YOUTH CENTER
AN ORGANIZATION CALLED IMPACT
JUSTICE. TO INITIATE A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAM THE
REDIRECT OUR YOUTH FROM THE
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THEY ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BUT THEY ALSO GET
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
INCLUDE INCLUDING SERVICE
PROVIDER CHAMA. TO REDUCE THE
PIPELINE INTO OUR SYSTEM TO
LOWER RECIDIVISM AND ALSO
REDUCE DISPARITIES- WE HAVE
FOUND IN OUR COUNTY THAT WE
HAVE RACIAL. AND EQUITY ISSUES
IN OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND SO PIECE OF POLICIES ARE
ALSO LOOKING AT THAT AS WELL.
THE OTHER THING WE I HAVE WHICH
IS A ROOM THAT IS ACTUALLY. OUR
YOU JUSTICE- SYSTEM WE'RE GOING
TO BE STUDYING AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE MY
EFFECTIVE WAY. TO INVEST IN OUR
JUST WITH THE BALL THROUGH RISK
JUSTICE AND COMMUNITY BASED
SOLUTIONS. WE'RE CURRENTLY
SPENDING OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
PER CHILD TO KEEP THEM LOCKED
UP. AND OFTEN THOSE-
ALTERNATIVES RESULT IN WORSE
OUTCOMES. FOR CHILDREN IN OUR
FAMILY- WE HAVE ALL USED
PROSECUTORIAL. AWAY FROM
CHARGING A CERTAIN OFFENSES
PARTICULARLY IN OUR ADULT
SYSTEM. FOR EXAMPLE AN EXAMPLE
OF THAT WOULD BE WITH THOSE WHO
SUFFER FROM DRUG ADDICTION AND
THOSE WHO SUFFER FROM MENTAL
ILLNESS. WHAT THE FENCES BOB
FOR THE FIRST ON A FEW
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE TO-
HAVE A PERSON COMING INTO OUR
OFFICE BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
ARRESTED WE ARE NOW SENDING
THOSE CASES INTO TREATMENT
PARTNERING WITH THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT TO DO SO- AND I
THINK THE FINAL ONE THAT I
WOULD LIFT ACTIVATE. ITS WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT RECIDIVISM
REDUCING RECIDIVISM- WE- I
WOULD. ARE USING OUR OUR POWER
OF OUR OFFICE NOT ONLY TO. GET
RID OF ALL FELONY AND
MISDEMEANOR CONVICTIONS THAT
ARE ON RCORD THAT PEOPLE KEEP
PEOPLE FROM BEING PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY KEEP
THEM OUT OF JOBS AND SO FORTH.
BUT ALSO USING A POWER UNDER
THE MORE RECENT LEGISLATION. ON
POST CONVICTION BE SENTENCING
TO TAKE A LOOK BACK AT ALL
THREATEN FOR THE RECOMMENDED
THE COURTS CHANGES. SO I THINK
THAT IN ADDITION TO. MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE TRAINING IN
PLACE WE HAVE PARTNERED WITH
THE VERA INSTITUTE- ARE THAT
IT'S A PARTNERSHIP THAT ALLOWS
US TO USE THAT DATA TO TAKE A
CRITICAL LOOK AT OUR OWN
DECISION MAKING. AND TO USE
THAT DATA TO DRIVE OUR POLICIES
GOING FORWARD AS WE ALSO FIFTY
IN RACIAL AND IMPLICIT. BIAS IN
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM. SO I THINK
IN THAT TIME THAT WE HAVE A- I
ALSO MY REMARKS THERE- IF YOU
WILL CLICK THAT FLY YOU'LL BE A
TO SEE ALL OF THE OTHER CHART-
THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
PUT IN PLACE. IF WE CAN HAVE
THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE REMAINING-
FIVE. ALBANY PUBLIC TIME THANK
YOU.
DO WE HAVE THREE BERBER
SELF ARE AVAILABLE. IF YOU
START TALKING A POP UP ON THE
SCREEN. THEY KNOW CAN EVERYBODY
HEAR ME. YES YEAH OKAY GREAT
SUPER SO THANKYOU BECAUSE
WITHOUT THE LEGISLATION EVEN
GIVING US IN THE TOOLS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN GIVING US WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
CHANGE THAT OUR COMMUNITY SO
DESPERATELY NEED SO IF I MAKE A
PAGE TO- WE HAD TO TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT WHO WE ARE WHAT WE WERE
DOING AND THE IMPACT THAT WE
HAD ON THE COMMUNITY. AND WE
HAD TO REIMAGINE OUR APPROACH
TO MEET THOSE CORE OBJECTIVES
AND SO WE SAID TO OURSELVES
WHAT WE REALLY GOING TO DO HERE
WE HAVE TO REDUCE CRIME I COME
FROM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY WE HAVE
A HIGH RATIO CRIME HERE WE HAVE
HIGH ECONOMIC CHALLENGES AND WE
NEED TO REDUCE THAT CRIME THAT
IMPACT OUR COMMUNITY AND REDUCE
OUR RECIDIVISM RATE. AND WE
NEED TO DO SO BECAUSE WE'RE
PREVENTING VICTIMIZATION AND
SPY STRENGTHENING OUR FAMILIES
AND OUR YOUTH AND THE
STRENGTHENING OUR COMMUNITIES
IN THE END MUSIN EBELING THEM
WORK AND EMPLOYMENT SO THESE
WERE KEY FACTORS IN DARK
DRIVING WHO WE ARE AND WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATION IN THE VOTER
APPROVED INITIATIVES WE'RE
MAKING SOME PROGRESS IN THIS
AREA SO LET ME FIRST AGAIN
THANK YOU. NEXT PAGE PLEASE. SO
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE CONTINUE
APPROACH TO JUSTICE WHAT ARE WE
DOING. AND WE EVEN GO FURTHER
BACK INTO PREVENTION AND IT AND
IT INTERVENTION AND- EDUCATION.
WE SPEAK TO TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS AND ADULTS EVERY
YEAR PRE COBIT- WITHOUT ALLOWED
US TO REALLY GET IN THERE
TRYING TO DO AS MUCH
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SCHOOLS.
AS WE COULD. WE GOT IT WE GOT
IT OUR TRUANCY AND WE CHANGED
OUR APPROACH TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
ON CAMPUSES. IN ORDER TO GET A
MORE HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS. AND
BUILD THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AT
TRUST AND TRANSPARENCY. AS WELL
AS PREVENTING THEM INDIVIDUALS
BECOME BECOMING GOT INVOLVED IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND THEN AT THE DEFLECTION
PERIOD. LOWER LEVEL BEHAVIORS
RESULTING IN PROGRAM REFERRALS
OR SCHOOLS OR LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOR YOUTH ARE HOMELESS AND
FAMILIES. ARE CRITICAL ISSUES
THAT OUR COMMUNITY SEES EVERY
DAY AS YOU KNOW MANY PEOPLE
WANT US TO ARREST AND PROSECUTE
PEOPLE FOR POVERTY DRIVEN-
FENCES. SO WE REALLY HAD TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND SAY
OKAY WHAT ARE WE DOING AND HOW
IS THAT MAKING OUR COMMUNITY
BETTER. BY BRINGING SOMEBODY IN
FOR AN OFFENSE THAT REALLY
NEEDS PROGRAMMING SUCH AS
SUBSTANCE USE MENTAL HEALTH AND
POVERTY. AND SO WE CHANGED OUR
APPROACH TO THAT AND DEFLECTED
AS MANY CASES AS WE COULD. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARRESTED COLLECTION
PROGRAM. AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
OTHER COMMUNITY AND FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TO LIFT
PEOPLE UP. INSTEAD OF
INFLICTING MORE HARM FOR WHICH
THEY CAN NEVER GET OUT FROM
UNDER SO WE REALLY SPENT A LOT
OF TIME ON HOW DO WE DO THIS
PRE ARREST MOTION. AND THEN
DIVERSION. OKAY PREC PRE
CONVICTION WERE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND AT FIRST WE
THOUGHT LET'S LOOK AT YOU KNOW
THAT'S A YOUNG GROUP SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY. AND I
GETS A FELONY CONVICTION GETS A
FELONY CHARGE. HOW CAN WE
PREVENT THIS FROM OCCURRING
BECAUSE YOU'RE LOOKING AT SIX
SEVEN EIGHT DECADES. OF THIS
INDIVIDUAL LIVING WITH THIS
FELONY CONVICTION ON HIS OR HER
THEIR THEM'S RAP. AND WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN TO THEM. TO THEIR
FAMILY TO THE COMMUNITY. AND
THE ECONOMICS OF IT ALL AND SO
WE REALLY LOOKED. AT THAT GROUP
NOW WE'VE EXPANDED TO THIRTY
THANKS TO THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A THE LAST. GAVE US.
AND NOW WORK. IT INTO FAMILIES.
STORE ARE ACTUALLY GONNA TAKE
THE MONEY THAT YOU'VE GIVEN US
ON OUR DIVERSION PROGRAM PNCC
IN THE CUP PNCC PLUS WE'RE
MOVING INTO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AN AREA THAT. A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE AFRAID TO GO INTO. BECAUSE
OF THE POTENTIAL FOR GREATER
HARM. BUT IN REALITY THERE'S NO
ONE AREA WHERE WE CAN DO MORE
GREAT WORK THEN RIGHT THERE.
BECAUSE WE SEE IN THESE HOMES
WHERE THEY'RE STRUGGLING WITH
ISSUES. THAT THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
NOT ONLY THOSE LIVING IN THE
HOUSE THE GRANDPARENTS AND
UNCLES AND AUNTS AND COUSINS
AND NEPHEWS IN THE NEIGHBOR'S.
AND THE PEOPLE ON THE BLOCK ARE
ALL IMPACTED. BY A HOME THAT IS
DEALING WITH TRAUMA. SO WE CAN
GET IN THERE AND REALLY DO SOME
GREAT WORK WE CAN CHANGE THE
OUTCOMES AND KEEP PEOPLE FROM
COMING BACK WHILE GIVING THEM
THE TOOLS. TO BE SUCCESSFUL
GOING FORWARD SO THIS IS A BIG
AREA AS WELL THAT WE MADE HUGE
MOVEMENT IN. AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REDUCE OUR RECIDIVISM
RATE BY HALF. IF WE DID A PILOT.
OF THE MEMBERS OF OUR-
COMMITTEE- I CLIENTS WHO
AGAINST. INDIVIDUALS WHO OPTED
NOT FOR THE PROGRAM BUT HAD
SAME OR SIMILAR CHARGES SAME OR
SIMILAR CRIMINAL HISTORIES. AND
WE CUT OUR RECIDIVISM RATES. BY
HALF. SO THIS CAN AND DOES WORK
AND YOU CAN USE THESE TOOLS. TO
ENHANCE INCREASE THINGS AND
INTEGRATE WORK AND THE LAST
THING WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THREE ENTRY. YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
PROGRAM HERE THAT ALLOWS RETURN
EXISTENCE TO HAVE A FAIR CHANCE
TO CLEAN UP THE CRIMINAL
RECORDS. AND GAVE ME A PHONE
PROGRAM. A WE HAVE READY TO
WORK WHICH IS A PROGRAM THAT
THEY COULD STAY UP TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS- RELEASE FROM BACK
COUNTY JAIL. OR PAROLE AND
HOPEFULLY NEXT YEAR EVEN
SPENDING THEIR LAST YEAR THERE.
THEY CAN WORK IN THE COMMUNITY
THEY DO PUBLIC SERVICE
COMMUNITY WORK ALL DAY LONG
THEY LEAVE WITH FIRST AND LAST
MONTH'S RENT PERMANENT HOUSING.
AND RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
SUBSTANCE USE- THINGS LIKE OF
THAT NATURE SO IT'S JUST A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY. SO I WANTED
TO THANK ALL OF YOU AND YOU CAN
SEE ON THIS LAST PAGE I'LL JUMP
OFF THE TIME I THINK IT'S
EXPIRED HERE BUT- WE HAVE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED FEWER YOUTH
ARRESTED SAN JOAQUIN. THANKS TO
PROP SIXTY FOUR STRUCTURE
DIVERSION PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM BY NEARLY 80% FOR
OUR PARTICIPANTS. AND TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND SENTENCES HAVE
BEEN REDUCED WAS SENTENCED
BURKE SMASHED. BUT WE ALSO TAKE
IT ONE STEP FURTHER WITH CLEAR
TEN THOUSAND BENCHMARKS. FOR
OLD CASES LIKE 1-137-711-3644
POSSESSION AND POSSESSION OF A
PIPE. BECAUSE PEOPLE GET
ARRESTED FOR THAT OUTSTANDING
BENCH WORK FROM NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN- AND THEN HAVE TO WAIT
FORTY EIGHT HOURS FOR THEIR DAY
IN COURT. SO THOSE KINDS OF
RECORD CLEARANCE THOSE TOOLS
ARE SO VALUABLE. THE OTHER
THING WE REALLY DESPERATELY
NEED FINES AND FEES ARE OUT OF
CONTROL AND EXCESSIVE. I KNOW
THERE'S MONEY COMING IN JUNE
AND THAT IS FANTASTIC THANK YOU
FOR THAT BUT THE FINES AND FEES
WE REALLY HAVE TO BE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
PEOPLE ECONOMICALLY- WHEN
THEY'RE TRAVELING THIS AND TO
REMEMBER THAT DMV IS GOING TO
HIT I'M PROBABLY MOST LIKELY AS
WELL. JUST A STEEP. AND THEN
AUTOMATIC SEALING WE JUST NEED
TO BE AUTOMATIC. GIVE PEOPLE A
CHANCE IF THEY HAVE HIGHER
FELONY CONVICTION. AND THEN
ATTACH IT FIRST OF. ARE FOR.
ARE ARE BIG. IN JUSTICE FOR ALL
THOSE ARE CREEK HE- AREA. SO
THANK YOU THE LAST OF COURSE.
THE CONFLICT IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR ME PLEASE LET ME
KNOW AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. I'M NOT
ENTIRELY SURE BUT I THINK I'M
NEXT. SO I'M JUST GONNA START
TALKING MY NAME IS PETER HAS
BEEN AWESOME THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF DIVERSION AND
REENTRY FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. ORGANIZATION THAT WAS
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN AND PLACED WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES.
WE HAVE FOUR BUCKETS OF WORK
INCLUDING OUR JAIL BASED
DIVERSION. WORK WHICH I'M GONNA
TALK ABOUT TODAY. OUR COMMUNITY
BASED DIVERSION WORK OUR
REENTRY. WORK WHICH WILL BE
ADDRESSED BY THE DIRECTOR OF
REENTRY SERVICES VANESSA MARTIN
WHO'S JOINING ME ON THIS CALL.
AND OUR YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
DIVERSION PROJECT. I'M I'M
GONNA FOCUS AND I'M TALKING
FAST BECAUSE I. I'M SHARING
THIS TIME WITH ANNOUNCED I
WANTED MAKE SURE THAT SHE HAS A
TIME. PRESENT PROGRAM. I'M
GONNA FOR OUR PRE TRIAL THE-
PROGRAM AND OUR- BEST CB ARE
PROGRAM. THE MISSION OF THE
OFFICE OF DIVERSION AND REENTRY
IN REGARDS TO JAIL BASED
VERSION IS TO REDUCE THE
POPULATION OF INMATES IN THE
COUNTY JAIL WHERE THEY ARE
BECAUSE THEY SUFFER FROM
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER OR ARE
CO MORBID WITH THE TWO- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT-
TODAY POST CODE OR- IN THE
MIDDLE OF CULVERHOUSE DEPENDING
ON YOUR BILL IT. OUR POPULATION
OUR DAILY CENSUS IN THE JAIL
WAS REDUCED FROM SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND TO AROUND FIFTEEN FELT
TODAY. UNFORTUNATELY THAT
POPULATION. AND MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND INMATES WHO ARE IN
SOME FORM OF MENTAL HEALTH
POLICY. AND IT'S OUR MISSION TO
HOLES MANY OF THOSE FOLKS OUT.
AND GET THEM INTO SOME SORT OF
THE BASE RESTORATION A
COMMUNITY BASED CARE. FIRST
THING I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS
OUR PRE TRIAL DIVERSION PROGRAM
WHICH WAS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW JUDGES.
AND JUST SO THE RECORD IS CLEAR
ON A RETIRED JOHN CHIANG A
LONGER. LONGER ON THE VENTURE
WHAT DEPARTMENT OF BILLS HELLO
JUDGES. DIVERT INDIVIDUALS
WHOSE CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR. IS
LARGELY THE RESULT OF AN
ONGOING MENTAL ILLNESS. OR
OTHER ON MATH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. ON BECAUSE OUR- MISSION
INVOLVES THE REDUCTION OF THE
COUNTY JAIL POPULATION OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND BECAUSE VERY
FEW MISDEMEANORS ARE HELD IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY JAIL. OUR
WORK FOCUSES ON PEOPLE IN THE
pFELONY. AND SO WE HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS IT'S A THREE
YEAR CONTRACT. AND IT PROVIDES
FOR TWO HUNDRED ONGOING SLOTS
WHICH MEANS IT AT ANY GIVEN
TIME WE WILL HAVE TWO HUNDRED.
SOMETIMES A LITTLE MORE WHICH
SHOWING A LOT OF OUR OWN MONEY
TO INCREASE THAT NUMBER BUT-
TWO HUNDRED. INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE UNDERGOING A DIVERSION
PROGRAM. THEY ARE RELEASED TO
US FOR CARE WE PROVIDE WITH
HOUSING. WRAPAROUND CLINICAL
SERVICES IN INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES ALL RIGHT.
SO THAT. WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT.
WE ADDRESS YOUR FRIEND IN A
RECIDIVIST BEHAVIOR AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY STAY MAD WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT OUR
POPULATION. APICALLY HOUSE OF
VERY HIGH MENTAL HEALTH
SECURITY IS OUR FOLKS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE NOT ONLY DECADES OF
MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUES BUT
DECADES OF HOMELESSNESS- WE
HAVE SERVED IN OUR TWO HUNDRED
LOTS OF THIS PROGRAM IS PRETTY
YOUNG IT'S WATSON TWO YEARS
OLD. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
PEOPLE WHO WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
BEEN IN THE COUNTY JAIL SO AS
THEY COMPLETE THEIR DIVERSION
PROGRAM IN THE CASE OF THE
PROJECT THAT'S- A LOT OF OUR
BAD WE BRING. SOMEONE ELSE.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE DON'T DO
THIS WORK OURSELVES THAT WE
CONTRACT WITH COMMUNITY BASED.
PROVIDERS WHO- PROVIDE IS OUR
Mà FOR ALL OF OUR APPROACH.
PROGRAMMING BY THE WAY WE'RE
NOTLARGE. ORGANIZATIONS PRETTY
LEAN. ON AND ALL THE WORK
THAT'S DONE IS OVERSEEN BY OUR
CLINICAL DIRECTOR. THIRTEEN AND
THEN COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS
BUT TAKE A BREATH. THEN I'M
GONNA MOVE ONTO OUR FIST CPR
PROGRAM. FELLAINI INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL. WE ALSO HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
STATE HOSPITALS TO ADDRESS THIS
POPULATION LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AT THE MOMENT TODAY THERE ARE
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED. PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS WHO HAVE BEEN DECLARED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL WHO
RUN THE STATE HOSPITAL WAIT.
WAITED TO BE TRANSPORTED. THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS TO
RECEIVE THEIR RESTORATION
SERVICES WHEN THEY ARE
INCOMPETENT FAIR CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS JUDGE IN OUR
STANDARD THEY'RE RELEASED TO
AUCTION WE MOVE THEM INTO THE
COMMUNITY WE TAKE THEM OFF THE
STATE HOSPITAL WAIT LIST. AT
THE COMMUNITY FOR A COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION SERVICE. OUR
CONTRACT REGIONALLY GEN THREE
YEAR CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
ALLOW FOR US TO CARE FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN PATIENTS AT ONE
TIME- AND WE RECENTLY. CREATED
AN EXPANSION AND- EXTENSION.
VENTURA CONTRACT WE WILL NOW BE
ABLE TO HELP SIR FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN. WALDRON TIME IN
OUR COMMUNITY BASED CARE AND TO
DATE WE HAVE SIR FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR AND THAT'S
UTILIZING TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN
SPOTS BECAUSE WE'VE JUST
LAUNCHED THE EXTENT OF. WHAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
LEGISLATURE TO APPRECIATE AND
UNDERSTAND THE NIGHT I KNOW
THAT YOU DO THAT- YOU KNOW OUR
OUR WE'RE FAMOUS OUR PHILOSOPHY
IS YOU CAN'T GET WELL IN A CELL
IT'S NOT HUMANE- IT'S NOWHERE
TO TREAT SOMEONE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS SHOULD SO. THE
ADVANTAGE TO BRING IN PEOPLE UP
GETTING. TREATMENT IN THE
COMMUNITY AND CARING FOR THEM
AND STABILIZING THEM IN THE
COMMUNITY. IT'S A PUBLIC SAFETY
STRATEGY IT IS A SOUND FISCAL
POLICY IT'S MUCH. LESS COSTLY
THAN CARING FOR THEM IN THE
JAIL OR THE STATE HOUSE WOULD.
I'M GOING TO. TURN THE REST OF
MY TIME OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
THE NASA MARKET TALK ABOUT OUR
REENTRY. THANKS SO MUCH.
ANOTHER- HI ALL I AM MY NAME IS
VANESSA MARTIN IS A DESERT IN
NORTHERN MENTIONED I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE RE ENTRY
DIVISION OF THE OFFICE OF
DIVERSION REENTRY IN L. A.
COUNTY I AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHLIGHT
EVERY ENTRY INITIATIVES IN L.
A. COUNTY THANK YOU AGAIN TO
TERRAN KIRKSEY AND MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING FORMER. FOR THE
PRODUCTION STATUTES- AS OUR
OTHER PANELISTS MENTIONED-
THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT LEAD
ACETATE LEGISLATION IN RECENT
YEARS TO REFORM THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS ALL THE
COMMITMENT BY THE STATE TO
REINVEST. FUNDS TO
INCARCERATIONS COMMUNITIES.
OPPOSITION PARTIES. AS OF THOSE
ARE. THAT WE ARE PRIMARY SOURCE
OF FUN FOR A RE ENTRY SERVICES.
THE FOCUS OF MY TESTIMONY IS
OUR OUR TWO MAJOR PROP FORTY
SEVEN FUNDED INITIATIVES. THE
FIRST OF THE REENTRY INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES
PROGRAM OR ARE A CMS FOR SHORT
YOU'LL FORGIVE ME WITH ALL THE
ACRONYMS AS WE GO THROUGH THIS-
SO OUR SMS CONNECTS
INDIVIDUALS. TO CASE MANAGERS
CALLED COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE
THE COMPLEX SOCIAL SERVICE
LANDSCAPE UPON RELEASE FROM
CUSTODY AS WELL AS PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND MOTIVATION AS THEY
START REBUILDING THEIR LIVES.
WHAT DISTINGUISHES IT FROM
TRADITIONAL CASE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS ARE PEOPLE WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE OF
INCARCERATION OR CREDIBLE
MESSENGERS. I'M WHO UNDERSTAND
FIRST HAND WHAT THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH IN THE HARDSHIPS THEY
FACED. BECAUSE MANY INDIVIDUALS
LACK POSITIVE SUPPORT NETWORKS
TO RETURN TO WHEN THEY WERE TO
RUN RELEASED FROM CUSTODY.
TRINITY HEALTH WORKERS MAKE A
BIG DIFFERENCE IN HELPING THEM
OVERCOME CHALLENGES AND STAYING
ON TRACK. TO ACHIEVE THEIR
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL GOALS.
SINCE OUR IS A MUST- BEGAN.
THREE YEARS AGO IN APRIL TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. WE HAVE
BUILT A NETWORK OF TWENTY NINE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WITH OVER A HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS. AND SERVED
ALMOST EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. A THIRD PARTY
EVALUATION OF ARI CMS'S
CURRENTLY BEING CONDUCTED WE DO
HAVE SOME EARLY FINDINGS THAT
SHOW THAT OUR ESTIMATES USES
STRONG. RESEARCH INFORMED
STRATEGIES INCLUDING GROWING
CATCHMENT PRIOR TO REENTRY.
CLIENT WEEKLY CLIENT
INTERACTIONS SMALL CASELOADS
AND EMPLOYING STAFF OF LIVED
EXPERIENCE IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. I'M ALSO SAYING THAT
OUR ESTIMATES MAY BE WELL
PLACED TO GENERATE COST SAVINGS
THROUGH REDUCTIONS IN
RECIDIVISM. OUR OTHER MAJOR
PROP FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED
PROGRAMS CALLED SECTOR WHICH
STANDS FOR THE SKILLS AND
EXPERIENCE FOR THE CAREERS OF
TOMORROW. SECTOR OFFER SKILLS
TRAINING AND PAID WORK
EXPERIENCE IN HIGH GROWTH
SECTORS THAT OFFER CAREER
PATHWAY OPPORTUNITIES AND
FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGES. SECTOR
PROGRAM ALSO PROVIDES CRITICAL
CHIANG WRAPAROUND SUPPORT AND
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
INTERVENTIONS. TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS AT HIGHER RISK OF
RECIDIVISM BILL PROBLEM SOLVING
AND COMMUNICATION SKILLS TO
ENSURE SUCCESS IN THE WORKPLACE.
IN ADDITION TO PROGRAMS FOCUSED
ON ENGAGING AND WORKING WITH
EMPLOYERS TO DEVELOP TRAININGS
AND JOB OPPORTUNITIES. AND TO
CHANGE MINDSETS ABOUT HIRING
BETWEEN MARCH IT'S A HUGE
BARRIER TO OVERCOME. SO SECTOR
LAUNCHED IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- WITH TEENS SIX
TRINITY BATES PROVIDERS. AND
ONLY A FEW SHORT MONTHS OVER
TWO HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS HAVE
BEEN ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM.
THIRTY NINE OF WHOM HAVE
COMPLETED TRAINING AND GIVEN
THE CURRENT PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT
WILL LIKELY EXCEED OUR PROGRAM
ENROLLMENT GOAL OF FIVE HUNDRED
FOR THE YEAR. IN CLOSING I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE OUR POLICYMAKERS
THAT LIKE ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES
SAWYER. I'M WHO HAVE FOUGHT FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. I
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO.
WHAT WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
FUNDING WE HAVE AS MANY OF OUR
PANELISTS DISCUSSED. WE ONLY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MEET A
FRACTION OF THE NEEDS SPECIAL
IN L. A. COUNTY WORDS. WHICH
ARE MORE FUNDING IS NEEDED TO
SUSTAIN AND EXPAND OUR PROGRAMS
AGAIN GIVEN THE MASSIVE SIZE
AND NEEDS OF THE- POPULATION-
FINALLY. AS I ALWAYS WANT TO
REMIND. THAT I KNOW- I DON'T
STATE TO THIS GROUP BUT- WE DO
NEED TO HAVE COMPASSION AND
CONTINUE TRAPPER PROGRAMS THE
POLICY INFORMED BY THE
EXPERIENCES. OF THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED AND IMPACTED BY
THE CHAPLAIN- ON THIS NOTE I
WOULD LIKE TO END WITH A QUOTE
FROM ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS. SCHERING MY
LIVED EXPERIENCES OF HOW I
OVERCAME ADVERSITY ADDICTION
AND DISCRIMINATION IN MY OWN
LIFE IT'S A TESTAMENT THAT REAL
CHANGE IS POSSIBLE GIVEN THE
RIGHT FOR. WHEN WE CAN RETURN
TO LIFE- I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
THE MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND- AND FELLOW PANELISTS TO
VISIT OUR REENTRY PROGRAMS. AND
THE TRANSPORTATION. OF THE
MARKET. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING
QUESTIONS. KEITH THANK YOU TO
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS I HAVE A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS BUT I'M
ONLY GOING TO ASK WANT TO GIVE
MY COLLEAGUES AN OPPORTUNITY
FAST ANYMORE- END OF BOTH A-
JUDGE ESPINOSA AND OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY- TORY RIVER CELLS ARE-
I GUESS EVERYONE I SEE TOUCH
AND IT BUT MAYBE IF I COULD
HAVE ONE OF THEM ANSWER-
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF RESEARCH
THAT INDICATES THAT. THESE
PROGRAMS THE TO REDUCTIONS IN
RECIDIVISM AND BETTER PUBLIC
SAFETY OUTCOMES AND IN ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND POLICIES ARE
IN YOU- THERE IS CONCERNS ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WERE
REDUCING ACCOUNTABILITY- THAT.
WERE NOT- PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
OUT THERE INTO CAN YOU GUYS
GIVE EITHER TO DATA- ADDED
THOUGH IT'S- AND ANSWER TO THAT
BUT YOUR PERSPECTIVE OF HOW
THESE PROGRAMS AND HALLAM'S.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ALSO
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY. I HAVE
AN ANSWER BUT I'M WILLING TO
DEFER TO. THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
TO GO FIRST IT SHOULD LARA.
OKAY THANK YOU YOUR HONOR I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
WE HAVE- SO WE WOULD WE WHAT WE
DO WITH OUR PNCC PROGRAM IS
WE'VE DONE IT WE'VE HAD IT FOR
ABOUT THREE YEARS AND CALL NOW
AND WE DID AN ANALYSIS BASED ON
THE INDIVIDUALS. THEY STILL
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY AND WE
HAVE BIG TO ME GAUGE MINT ARE
VICTIMS ARE FULLY INFORMED OF
THE PROGRAM AND ARE PART OF THE
JOURNEY WITH US BECAUSE IT
USED. A CD OVERWHELMING
RESEARCH TELLS US ARE VICTIMS
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN SO WE'RE DOING
PROPERTIES ASSAULTS GUN CASES
WERE DOING SERIOUS WERE IN THE
MODERATE RANGE WE'VE MOVED FROM
LOW LEVEL BECAUSE WE SAW THE
RISKS OF THE RESULT WE FELT
CONFIDENT IN IT WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES WERE BEING ADEQUATELY
USED. AND NOW WE'VE MOVED TO
MORE MODERATE BEHAVIOR THAT IS
THAT HIGH RISK GROUP ESPECIALLY
FOR YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN UNDER
THE AGE OF THIRTY ANSWER WE DID
AN ANALYSIS BASED ON
INDIVIDUALS THAT IT- CAME INTO
THE PROGRAM I COMPLETED THE
PROGRAM VERSUS THOSE WHO DID
NOT WITH SAME OR SIMILAR
CHARGES IN SAME OR SIMILAR
CRIMINAL HISTORY AN AGING
FACTORS. AND LIKE I SAID OUR
GROUP IS AS AND HALF THE
RECIDIVISM RATE- AS THE GROUP
THAT DID NOT ENGAGE IN THIS
PROGRAMMING SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
IT FROM ITS TOTALITY WE STILL
HAVE THEM TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
THEY WERE STILL IN COURT AND
THEY STILL HAVE KNOWLEDGE THE
HARM THAT THEY COMMITTED AND
THE VICTIM HAD A RIGHT TO SPEAK
AND DO RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FOR
THEM IF THEY SO CHOOSE TO. IF
NOT THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO BUT
THEY ALSO ALWAYS MOST CASES
SENT A MESSAGE AS TO WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM THEIR JOURNEY
AND WHAT THEIR HOPE WAS FOR
THIS INDIVIDUAL AND SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT THAT NOW WE KNOW WE CAN
TAKE IT TO THAT NEXT LEVEL AND
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE INTO A MORE
FAMILY HARM- WHICH IS THE IS A-
BIG AREA BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IN A
LOT A LOT OF. A PROGRAMMING IN
THIS AREA THAT HAS SHOWN TO BE
OF VALUE SO WE DO BELIEVE WE
CAN STAND BEHIND OUR RESULTS
AND WE DO BELIEVE AND I AM A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY I NEVER WAS
GOING TO GET INTO THIS BUSINESS
TO BE IN THIS LANGUAGE. AND I'M
A FIRM BELIEVER OF IT BECAUSE
IF I CAN LOWER MY RECIDIVISM
RATE. I CAN'T WILL KEEP VICTIMS
SAFE AS WELL AT THE SAME TIME
AND SE RI. SO THAT THERE IS A
DATA RE. UP THERE THAT IS. THAT
IT IS ORK. AND THAT RESPECT
ACCEPTING RESPONSIBILITY IS
PART OF THE JOURNEY. TOLD ME
ON. TRY TO ANSWER IT FROM A
DIFFERENT LENS THROUGH A
DIFFERENT LENS ONE OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE- OPERATE THAT
I DIDN'T DISCUSSES OUR FELONY
PRE TRIAL PROGRAM. AND WE ARE
DIVERTING PEOPLE. DIVERGENCE
NOT THE RIGHT WORD WE ARE
ACCEPTING PEOPLE WHO HAVE PLED
GUILTY OR BEEN PLACED ON
PROBATION LOW MOSTLY FOR
SERIOUS FELONIES BECAUSE OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY JAIL. THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT'S LEFT OF PEOPLE
CHARGED WITH. SERIOUS CRIMES-
REDUCE THIS IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT
OUR COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS
IN THE COURT. RAMPS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED- FOLKS WHO ARE ON
PROBATION LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FOR FELONY. IN OUR HOUSE AND
THE RAND CORPORATION. I DID A
STUDY OF THIS PROGRAM AFTER ITS
FIRST YEAR. BERMAN AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT OUR POPULATION. ON IT IT
HAS A HIGH MENTAL HEALTH ACUITY
ALONG WITH CO MORBID S. U. D.
CONDITIONS AND SO THAT THERE
ARE DIFFICULT POPULATION TO
MANAGE WE HAVE MANAGED TO
MAINTAIN THEM AT AROUND 74%
HOUSING RETENTION RATE WHICH
MEANS THE COMPANY. EVEN THOUGH
THEY'VE BEEN HOMELESS FOR
DECADES- ANNA RECIDIVISM RATE
AT THE FOREIGN BY NEW FELONY
CONVICTION AROUND FIFTEEN
PERCENT- BUILDER GREAT PROPERTY
THAT IS DEFINITELY A PUBLIC
SAFETY AND IN LINE WITH THE
COUNTY IS CAREFUL WHICH JAIL
LAST LOSS WITH THE. BUT I WILL.
ECHO WHAT THE NET WE CERTAINLY
MORE OF THESE TO REDUCE THE
POPULAR IN THE JAIL. AND ONE
THE DALLAS ALL SALES KNOW WE
LOOK AT ALL OF OUR WORK
RACIALIST REYES APPLE LINE AND
I WILL TELL YOU THAT- IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT HEALTHY IN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY JAIL TO THAT
LEFT WHICH IS NOT CHAU. ARE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
MISS A LOT IF THANK YOU. I'M MY
QUESTIONS ARE MAINLY AROUND
PROP FORTY SEVEN AND SOME OF
THE WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING
INCREASES IN CRIMES THAT WE'VE
SEEN AS A PERTAINS TO PROPERTY
CRIME LARCENY SINCE THE
PASSAGE- TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN SAN JOAQUIN- AND-
CONTRA COSTA- OR HAVE YOU SEEN
AN INCREASE IN PROPERTY CRIME
AND LARCENY. WE. I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT- WE DO IT WE
WILL I HATE IT KNOWLEDGE IS
FALL- SINCE WE'VE BEEN IN
PUBLIC NIGHT TEAMFAST. WE
REALLY HAVE HAD MORE PINES OF
WHAT I MAKE OUR DESPERATION IN
OUR COMMUNITY- I WOULD SAY THAT
OVERALL WE DO SEE THAT THE
CRIME RATES ARE CONTINUING TO
DECREASE. BUT THAT IN CERTAIN
AREAS ESPECIALLY- AS PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN UNEMPLOYED IF PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN ON HOW WE HAVE SEEN
CERTAIN CRIMES SUCH AS THE
CATEGORIES THAT YOU HAVE
MENTIONED- TAKE FLIGHT IN
KUWAIT. AND SO- I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT REALLY ALL CLOSE TO
WHETHER OR NOT I POLICIES
OVERALL ARE WORKING I REALLY
THINK HE GOES TO THE CONDITIONS
UNDER WHICH WE'VE BEEN WORKING
IN THE LAST YEAR OR SO. AS
WE'VE BEEN CUT NINETEEN. SO I
WOULD JUST YOU KNOW. SAY THE
THERE HAS BEEN A STUDY THAT
SHOWN THE SINCE PROPERTIES
PROPERTIES THAT HAS NOT- HAS
AND- EVEN PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
AND YES I WOULD AGREE THAT. ON
THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN VERY DESPERATE
SITUATION SO WE WOULD EXPECT TO
SEE SOME OF THESE. CRIMES IS-
THE OTHER QUESTION I THINK-
SEAN. THAT'S YOUR MONEY IF I IF
I MAY HAVE BEEN TOO IS THAT I
DO BELIEVE WE'VE SEEN AN
INCREASE M. FROM PROP FORTY
SEVEN THAT WE HAVE SEEN
PROPERTY CRIMES GO UP BUT WHAT
I THINK IS THE REASON WHY IS WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM FOR IT I
KNOW AT LEAST IN MY COUNTY
THERE'S LIMITED CAPABILITIES OF
DOING A DEFLECTION OR DIVERSION
IN THESE CASES- AND THAT IS
REALLY AT IT TIED THE HANDS OF
VESTED TO CONNECT TO DIVERT. A
YEAR AND I THINK THE OTHER
ISSUE OU SEEN THE INCREASING
CRIME HAS BEEN IDENTITY THEFT
NOT FOR SURE HAS HAPPENED IN IN
MOST CITIES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
YOU CAN NECESSARILY CORRELATION
IS BETWEEN THOSE SPIKES BECAUSE
A PROP FORTY SEVEN OR THE LACK
OF POVERTY HAS INCREASED WITH
THE INCREASE IN OUR COMMUNITY
SIGNIFICANTLY SO HERE IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY 25% OF MY OF MY
COMMUNITY LIVES AT OR BELOW THE
POVERTY LEVEL ON TOP OF THAT
15% CANNOT SUSTAIN. A FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLAR MEDICAL
EMERGENCY SO 40% OF MY
COMMUNITY IS STRUGGLING
ECONOMICALLY AND I THINK THAT
PLAYS A KEY ROLE IN REALLY
SEEING THE INCREASE IN POVERTY
LEVEL OFFENSES AND THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE THEFT RELATED- AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SUBSTANCE
USE MOST OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT I'M DEALING WITH ON LARGE
SCALE IDENTITY THEFT CASES
WHICH ARE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF VICTIMS- ARE
ARE REALLY DRIVEN BY SUBSTANCE
SUBSTANCE. SUBSTANCE UNTREATED
MENTAL HEALTH I HAVE FORTY BEDS
IN RECOVERY I'M SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY YOU KNOW WE ARE VERY
SHORT ON THE ABILITY TO TAKE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ARE ARE
USING THEFT AS A MECHANISM TO
SUPPORT A HABIT OR MENTAL
HEALTH OR POVERTY AND REALLY
PLACE THEM IN A SITUATION WHERE
WE CAN REALLY ADDRESS THEIR
NEEDS SO WE HAVE WE HAVE SEEN
IT- BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT THE
CORRELATION IS NECESSARILY
BECAUSE OF FORTY SEVEN SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT THINK ONE ONLY
GONNA GET A MISDEMEANOR BUT
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO GET A
MISDEMEANOR IF THAT'S THE CASE.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS A
TREMENDOUS SPIKE. IN POVERTY
AND I BELIEVE WHEN KOBE WINDS
DOWN. THE ECONOMIC FOR BE. YOU
KNOW A BIG BIG FAN AS WELL SO.
WE'LL SEE. MY NEXT QUESTION
HAVE TO QUESTION THIS QUESTIONS
AND ONE MORE QUESTION- IS TO
JUDGE- ESPINOZA- IF I MAY YOU
MAY READ AND IN THE COUNTY AND
CITY OF LOS ANGELES WE HAVE
EIGHTY. AT CRISIS LEVEL
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM- DRUG
EPIDEMIC MATH UP ATOMIC BOMB
AND MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AT OUR
HANDS AND IT SEEMS LIKE THOSE
ARE ALL INTERCONNECTED AS WELL.
AND ARE. CITY I'M JUST GONNA
READ WHAT YOU KNOW ARE SOME OF
THE OFFICIALS- FROM BOTH LAPD
AND EVEN MAYOR GARCETTI HAVE
SPOKEN ON HIS. SENSE IT HAS
BEEN REGULATED NOW DOWN TO A
MISDEMEANOR THAT IS- POSSESSION
ARE THERE IS MORE OF A
REVOLVING DOOR WE DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO HAVE PEOPLE GO
INTO TREATMENT FACILITIES LIKE
WE HAD BEFORE SO IT HAD SOME
EFFECT ON THE STREET LEVEL. AND
THE MAYOR GARCETTI SAYS ALSO I
AGREE WITH THEM IF SOMEBODY
GETS ARRESTED THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO SERVE ANY JAIL TIME IF THEY
DO SERVE TIME IN JAIL THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE PROSECUTED. IF
THEY DON'T GET PROSECUTED IF
THEY DO GET PROSECUTED THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE SENTENCED AND
IF THEIR SENTENCE THERE OUT
RIGHT AWAY. IT'S A BROKEN
SYSTEM. I'D LIKE TO KNOW YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE SYSTEM BEING
BROKEN. AND HOW WE- NEED TO
INTERVENE- TWO TWO TWO
SOMETIMES DEMAND TREATMENT-
BECAUSE IT IS ALSO INCREASING
CRIME. SO MOST OF THE
LITERATURE THAT I'VE READ SEEMS
TO INDICATE THAT PORCH
TREATMENT IT'S NOT A SMALL
BOOKS NOT AS SUCCESSFUL AS
VOLUNTARY CARE AND TREATMENT
FOR PEOPLE WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SEEMS TO BE THE FOCUS
OF YOUR COMMENTS ON WHAT EXPERT
IN THIS AREA. BUT I HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT THE MASS
INCARCERATION THAT RESULTED ON
FELONY PROSECUTIONS FOR DRUG
POSSESSION. ON WERE NOT
HELPFUL. THERE WERE TOO MANY
PEOPLE IN STATE PRISON IN
COUNTY JAIL AND EVEN WHEN YOU
HAVE FORCED ON CARE PORSCHE
TREATMENT. THAT HAS TO BE
MATCHED WITH SOME RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE CARE AND TREATMENT
WHICH HAS NEVER BEEN THE CASE
AND SO I DON'T THINK THE ANSWER
IS FELONY PROSECUTIONS FOR
SIMPLE POSSESSION. ON TO END
HOMELESSNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER ARREST I DON'T THE
ANSWER IS SERVICE SERVICE THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF STRATEGIES WE
ARE HARM REDUCTION-
ORGANIZATION THATBELIEVES THAT
YOU HAVE TO MEET PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE. GET THEM STABILIZED
IN THE COMMUNITY AND BEGAN
DEALING WITH HER ON THAT HE HAD
REAL HEALTH NEEDS WHETHER IT'S
MENTAL HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS- I'M NOT SURE THAT IF
THE MAYOR SAYING WE NEED FELONY
PROSECUTIONS. TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN PROVIDING TREATMENT THAT I
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT BUT I'M
NOT SURE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT.
WHAT HE SAID. IN THE STATEMENT.
THANK YOU. AND LASTLY- TO THE
DA- IN IN SOME WALKING. I THINK
JUST- FIFTY SEVEN PEOPLE WERE
ARRESTED AND- TRAFFICKING AND
THOSE FIFTY SEVEN PEOPLE. ON
THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE MEETING
UP WITH A THIRTEEN YEAR OLD-
HAVE YOU SEEN AN INCREASE
BECAUSE ANECDOTALLY AND MY
COMMUNITY AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND VENTURA COUNTY.
ACROSS THE STATE- I FEEL LIKE
THERE IS A IN AND I'VE READ
THERE IS A GROWING PROBLEM WITH
CHILD HUMAN TRAFFICKING- IS
THERE AN INCREASE IN IN IN YOUR
COUNTY. I THINK THERE'S AN
INCREASE ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA I THINK IT
WORLDWIDE- I THINK WE ARE
DEFINITELY I THINK IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN THERE MAYBE WE JUST DIDN'T
SEE IT FOR WHAT IT WAS OFTEN
THAT WE WERE PROSECUTING YOU
KNOW YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN- IN IN
THE TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY YOU
NAME. AT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY YEARS OLD FOR WHAT WE
CONSIDERED IN THAT DAY
PROSTITUTION AND NOBODY EVER
SKED HOW DO YOU GET HERE. HOW
COME YOU'RE EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD
IN YOUR HERE HOW DID HOW DID
WHAT WAS YOUR JOURNEY INSTEAD
WE LOOKED AT IT AGAIN. AS DOING
HARM AND NOT REDUCING THE HARM
BY INCARCERATING EVERYBODY DOES
NOTHING BECAUSE IN THIS
SITUATION WE JUST TO COME IN
FOR A COUPLE DAYS. OF MAYBE TEN
TWENTY THIRTY DAYS DEPENDING ON
THE JUDGMENT EVEN AT THE TIME
AND THEN THEY WERE BACK OUT
WITH NO SERVICES NO OPPORTUNITY
TO BE LIFTED UP AND TO BE HILL.
SO WE REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT
THAT BECAUSE LIKE YOUR SCENARIO
BEFORE WITH THE PROP FORTY
SEVEN CASES SO IF YOU EVEN IF
YOU MOVED IT BACK TO A FELONY
CONVICTION FOR SAY IT USED TO
BE IN THE DAY THREE TO FIVE
PRIOR PETTY THEFTS WOULD GET
YOU A FELONY CONVICTION. AND
EVEN THEN A JUDGE WOULD GIVE
YOU LESS THAN A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS ON AVERAGE WHICH ALLOWS
YOU TO DO ALTERNATIVE WORK
PROGRAM SO YOU'RE NOT GOING
BACK IN FOR ANY PROGRAMMING
YOU'RE JUST DOING MORE JAIL
MORE FIT FEES OR FINES. AND
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO COME OUT
STILL HAVE MENTAL HEALTH STILL
HAVE SUBSTANCE USE ISSUES AND
STILL BE LIVING IN POVERTY
PROBABLY MORE POVERTY BECAUSE
OF WHAT WE DID. AND EVEN IF I
ONLY BOOK YOU FOR FORTY EIGHT
HOURS SAVE FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT TO DO IS DAY AND SOMETIMES
WATCHING CORPORATION DOES WORK.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
PEOPLE THAT ARE DRIVING FROM
POVERTY AND YOU GIVEN FORTY
EIGHT HOURS THAT'S STILL TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARSOF THE
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS FOR THE REST
OF THE PROSECUTION AND THE
DEFENSE AND THE COURT'S TIME.
BY THE TIME WE GET THERE SO
IT'S STILL A LOT OF MONEY AND
RESOURCES AND IF YOU'RE GOING
TO BE RELEASED AND THERE'S NO
MORE ADDITIONAL TIME AND NO
PROGRAMMING WE REALLY HAVEN'T
DONE ANYTHING EXCEPT SPENT
SPENT A LOT OF MONEY. AND THEN
CIRCLING BACK TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING YES ABSOLUTELY AND
WERE VERY AGGRESSIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY WE'RE CONSTANTLY
WORKING EVERY. TOOL AND
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE. THERE IS NOW A LOT
OF MONEY. OF FUNDING AND
MECHANO. SPAM FOR THE- WHICH IS
VERY LABOR INTENSIVE. BUT ALSO
THERE NEEDS TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN THE HEALING-
RIGHT NOW I'M WORKING WITH AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD. IN THE
EVENING I VOLUNTEER AND I GO
OUT TO THE HOMELESS CAMPS. AND
I WORK SPECIALLY SINCE COVERT
HAD STARTED. I HAVE AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD TRANSGENDER. YOUNG
FEMALE WHO COMES IN FOR A DAY
OR TWO THEN GOES BACK OUT FOR A
WEEK OR TWO. COMES IN FOR A DAY
GOES BACK OUT. WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE ANY FACILITY. THAT CAN
REALLY ADDRESS THE LONG TERM
TRAUMA. SHE WAS TRAFFIC IT'S
SINCE THE AGE OF TWELVE HER
GRANDMOTHER TURNED AROUND IN
EXCHANGE TO PAY OFF HER DEBTS
FOR THE DRUG LORDS THAT WERE
SELLING MONEY TO WORK. ARE
SELLING DRUGS TO HER. SHE'S
BEEN AND PROFITS FOR THE LAST
SIX YEARS HAS SUFFERED
TREMENDOUS PSYCHOLOGICAL
PHYSICAL AND SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES A NUMBER
OF THINGS HAVE GONE ON. WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS ALL OF THOSE
AND STABILIZER. A FEW MONTHS
AGO WHEN I WAS OUT ON THE
STREET I BROUGHT OUR FOOD IN
THE HOPES OF TRYING TO GET HER
TO COME BACK IN- HER.
TRAFFICKER SAAMI. HE TOOK HER
PHONE. AND HE TEXT LITERALLY
DEATH THREATS. TO ME YES
BECAUSE I KNOW WHO YOU ARE I
WON'T EVEN TELL YOU THE
LANGUAGE IT WAS HORRIFIC. AND
HE SAID YOU THINK YOU'RE GONNA
TAKE MY MONEY MAKER. I'LL KILL
YOU I'LL KILL HER TOO. THERE
WAS NO IF ANDS OR BUTS. IT IS A
VERY VIOLENT WORLD. AND IT IS A
VERY DANGEROUS WORLD AND IF WE
NEED TO HAVE. TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE CANNOT JUST GO GET
SOMEBODY OFF THE STREET AND
EXPECT IT TO BE PERFECT. BUT
THEY'RE GOING TO COME IN AND
THEY'RE GOING TO TRAVEL- I TO
ADVOCATES THAT ARE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS SURVIVORS.
IT TOOK ONE TEN YEARS. AND THE
OTHER TWO YEARS BEFORE WE CAN
FINALLY MOVE THEM. OUT OF THE
LIFESTYLE IF YOU WILL. IN INTO
SAFETY. SO I THINK THAT IF
YOU'RE WHERE YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
ESPECIALLY WE'RE SEEING SUCH AN
INCREASE WITH THE INTERNET.
OBVIOUSLY AND- READILY
AVAILABLE AND ACCESSIBLE. BUT
WE'RE SEEING IT ON THE STREET
IN THE- YOU KNOW IN THE OLD
DAYS ON THE BLADE RIGHT NOW.
ANYBODY THAT LOOKS UNDER
EIGHTEEN IS GOING FOR TWO TO
THREE TIMES THE MARKET VALUE-
THERE'S A YEAH I MEAN I COULD
TELL YOU HORRIFIC STORIES BUT I
DON'T WANT TO TRAUMATIZE.
EVERYBODY'S MONEY BUT IT'S A
CRITICAL ISSUE. IT'S AN X.
ISSU. AS WE AND I. MEAN TO.
AND I ON IT. BUT THE HEALING.
OF THE TRAFFIC VICTIMS IF YOU
YEARS AND YEARS IN THE MAKING.
AND THAT AND IT'S VERY COMPLEX.
AND SO WE WOULD APPRECIATE ANY
SUPPORT. ON BOTH SIDES WE NEED
MORE INVESTIGATIVE TOOLS
BECAUSE MOST OF THIS IS
HAPPENING ONLINE- AND THOUGH I
STILL HAVE A HIGH POPULATION ON
THE STREET. LIKE I SAID. AND
THEN THE OTHER PART IS THE
HEALING VERY CRITICAL FOR US TO
THANK YOU FOR SHINING A LIGHT
ON THIS. IT IS CRITICAL. THANK
YOU. MISTER DANCER I THANK YOU
AND THANK EVERYONE FOR THESE
QUESTIONS- FOR ME- BECAUSE I'VE
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR QUITE AWHILE- AND I'M KIND
OF. TIRED OF ANECDOTAL.
SUGGESTIONS OF WHAT'S GOING ON
I'M TIRED OF PEOPLE MAKING
CLAIMS AND IT IS WE'RE NOT A
POINT WHERE WE NOT HAVE TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN FACT WE
PROBABLY NEED A THIRD PARTY
GROUP. TO KIND OF LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE. AND DOCUMENTED BUT ALSO
COME UP WITH- WITH THE SPECIFIC-
DATA THAT SHOWS WHETHER IT'S
LOCKED THEM UP AND THROW AWAY
THE KEY AND KEEP HIM IN CARCERI
LONGER OR WE DO THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES BUT WE NEED TO GO OUT
TO THESE COMMUNITY GROUPS. AND
FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR NOT THESE
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY WORK AND IF
AND IF THEY DO THEN WE NEED TO
GIVE MORE MONEY TO THE PROGRAMS
THAT WORK AND DIVERT MONEY SOME
ONES THAT DON'T. CONVERSELY IF
THERE SOME PRISON PROGRAMS TO
JAIL PROGRAMS THAT WORK WE NEED
TO FUND THOSE TWO IF THERE'S
ANOTHER MIDWAY- WE CAN HANDLE
ALL THESE PROBLEMS- THAT HAVE
THAT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE. THEM WE NEED TO
COLLABORATE TOGETHER THE REASON
I SAY A THIRD PARTY GROUP WHICH
I AM I MAY EVEN RECOMMEND TO
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WILL DO THE
DATA COLLECTION AND ACTUALLY
LOOK AT WHAT PROGRAMS THAT WORK
MORE DON'T WORK. IS THAT WE
WE'VE GOT TO STOP FIGHTING OVER
THE MONTH AND WE NEED TO DIRECT
THE MONEY TO WEAR. THINGS ARE
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL. I'M FROM
FIRM BELIEVER THAT MAYBE ONE
PERSON. NEEDED TO BE DETAINED
AND- BROUGHT INTO A DRUG
PROGRAM AND THERE'S PROBABLY A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE THAT BE NEED
TO BE VOLUNTARILY SUBMIT
THEMSELVES BUT WE'VE GOT TO GET
TO THE AS AS THE PROP 47-57
POKER TALKING ABOUT. WE'VE GOT
TO GET TO THE CORE ISSUE. WE
CAN'T JUST PUT BANDAIDS ON
THINGS AND BANDAIDS OR THINGS
WE REALLY GOT TO GET TO THE
CORE ISSUES AND THAT'S REALLY
REALLY HARD WORK AND- BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT-
PEOPLE DELIGHT BOGUS AND TO.
TURN OVER OVERNIGHT AND SO I IF
THERE'S A WAY. THAT BOTH SIDES
CAN COME TO US AND GET MAYBE
EVEN TALK TO A THIRD PARTY-
MADAM CHAIRED A THIRD PARTY
GROUP THAT COULD COME UP WITH
SOME. WAYS TO MAKE THE SYSTEM A
LOT BETTER AND I INVITE INPUT
FROM YOU OPTION ONE. BY M.
COULD FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THEN NOW YOU JUST ADVOCATES BUT
JUST COMMUNITY FOLKS TO SAY OR
EVEN PEOPLE WHO WERE IN A LIFE
OR OR COMMITTING THE CRIME TO
SAY WHAT. COULD WE HAVE DONE.
TO MAKE SURE YOU DON'T
PARTICIPATE IN ANY OF THESE
ADVERSE- INDUSTRIES OR OR OR
CRIMES BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY- WE'VE GOT TO GET TO
THE CORE ISSUES IN THE ESTES
PARK YES IT'S ON. THE
ENVIRONMENT YOU GREW UP IN YES
W. SAYS YES IS THE MENTAL
HEALTH ASPECT OF IT WHICH A LOT
OF US DON'T EVEN WANT TO DEAL
WITH WE JUST KIND OF GLOSS
OVER. BUT THAT MAY BE THE MOST
CRITICAL PART OF THIS OF THIS
WHOLE CRIMINALITY. IS THAT- OF
WHAT PEOPLE ARE PEOPLE HAVE
GONE THROUGH AT A YOUNG AGE.
YOU KOW YOU YOU YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN A LIFE. AS IF THEY JUST
DECIDED TO BE IN IT BUT THEY
MAY HAVE BEEN RIGHT AT TEN OR
ELEVEN BY A BY A SPOT BY A
PARENT. BY ONGOING NOT. AND
THEN YOU WONDER WHY THEY'RE ON
THE STREET AT EIGHTEEN A MAYBE
BECAUSE- ALL OF THAT STUFF THAT
HAPPENED THAT THEY WON'T TALK
TO YOU ABOUT. AND IT WE ALSO
NEED TO QUANTIFY IT NOW LEAVE
YOU WITH THIS QUANTITY IF WE
QUANTIFY IT. ESPECIALLY THE
COST. WHICH IS REALLY HARD
BECAUSE REALLY IT'S EASY TO
SAY. X. AMOUNT OF ROBBERIES X.
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE ARE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING X. AMOUNT OF
MURDERS AND THAT COST X. AMOUNT
OF COST AVOIDANCE. IS REALLY
DIFFICULT. TO QUANTIFY IF I
TELL YOU THAT BECAUSE THIS
PROGRAM. X. AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
DID NOT RECEIVE THE BAIT THEN
WE SHOULD SAY WE HAD X. AMOUNT
OF SAVINGS. BUT HOW MANY OF
THEM DID NOT COMMIT A MURDER
HOW MANY OF THEM DID NOT BREAK
INTO SOMEONE'S HIGH MANY OF
THEM. THAT STUFF THAT'S REALLY
THE HARD PART TO TRY TO GET TO
THAT AND WE REALLY SHOULD.
BECAUSE COST AVOIDANCE IS HUGE
AND WHAT PEOPLE DO WITH PROP
47-57. THAT I THINK THAT NUMBER
IS. IS WILL DWARF. BUT I NEED
DATA. I NEED TO BE ABLE TO SAVE-
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
WE'RE DOING ALL THESE PROGRAMS-
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT HAVE
TO DO AS MUCH AND THEN THEY CAN
CONCENTRATE. ON MAY BE GOING TO
THE REALLY SERIOUS ONE SO. IF
YOU. IF YOU WANT TO WORK WITH
ME I WOULD REALLY GOING TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT A- AN INDEPENDENT
SOURCE TO DO THE KIND OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES SO THAT
WE BRING BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE.
THESE ARE THE NUMBERS THESE ARE
THE ACTUAL NUMBERS AND- AND WE
WERE NOT TAKEN KINDA ANECDOTAL
ANALYSIS BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
I MEAN WE'VE BEEN GOING BACK
AND FORTH BACK FORCES I GOT
HERE IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
WE'RE STILL DOING THE SAME
THING BUT WE GOT TO BRING IN
MORE DATA. SO THANK YOU. I WANT
TO THANK THE PANELISTS- A LOT
OF THESE POLICIES- ARE YOUNG
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR NINE YEARS A
LOT OF THESE POLICIES HAVE BEEN
WORKED ON SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE-
IT TAKES TIME- INDIVIDUALS ARE
NOT GOING TO OVERCOME TRAUMAS
THAT AND- THE AND THE FIRST
STEP OFTENTIMES AND SO. THAT
DATA IS IMPORTANT- BOOK. IN
THEM IN THE END- I THINK WE
NEED TO RELY ON BUT THE
COMMUNITY THE EXPERTS ARE
TALKING TO US ABOUT THE WORKING
WITH COMPASSION. OFF WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES OUT THERE. ASTERION
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS THE FORMER
CLASSROOM TEACHER- HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER I WOULD OFTEN HAVE TO
REMIND MYSELF THAT THESE WERE
KIDS- AND WHEN THEY MADE A
MISTAKE THAT THE SERVE SECOND
CHANCES AND OFTEN SCIENCES I
HAD A DISCUSSION WITH THEM IT
WAS. THE SITUATION THAT LEAD
THEM DOWN A PATH WITH THAT THEY
WERE NOT IS REALLY HAPPY WITH
THAT THE FATHER HAD OTHER
CHOICES OUT THERE ON AND SO I
JUST DO THINK THAT- WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO. TO FIGURE THIS
OUT NOT JUST BECAUSE I BUDGET I
NEED TO SEE WHAT THESE ARE
HUMAN BEINGS EVER TALKING ABOUT
OF ANY TO THAT NEED A SENSE OF
WHAT THAT I'M GOING TO BE
MINDFUL OF TIME WE DO HAVE A
HARD STOP OF TWELVE THIRTY- AND
SO I WANT TO THANK THE PANEL
FOR BEING HERE AND I'M GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT- WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT BOTH.
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT TO THE COMMITTEE. TO
THE COMMITTEE. IS ON THE
WEBSITE. IT'S ON THE AGENDA.
IT'S ON THE SCREEN OF YOUR
STREAMING THE HEARING. AND THEN
HERE IS THE NUMBER JUST IN
CASE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AGAIN THAT'S. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR. THREE SEVEN ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. EVEN
COUNT ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AT. 916-319-2099 AND
A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU
WE ALSO ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE. MADE IN PUBLIC TRUST
THE MONEY. WHICH CAN BE
SUBMITTED AT BUDGETS OF FIVE AT
ASM THAT CA DOT GOV AND IS ALSO
LISTED ON THE AGENDA. DO WE
HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM. SEE NINE OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
THE PUBLIC COMMENT EACH PERSON
HAS A TWO ONE MINUTE FOR THE
PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN WE DO HAVE
A HARD STOP. IN ABOUT HALF AN
HOUR. I WANT TO BE MINDFUL OF
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LADIES AND JUMP YOU DO HAVE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN IT'S. ONE ZERO. NO
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC. OKAY
THERE'S THE PUBLIC MY COMMENTS
ON I THINK THE MEMBERS- ANDTHE
PANELISTS AND THE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK AND WE WILL RETURN
TO THE THINKING- MODERATOR. YOU
VERY MUCH.